Hallo herzlich willkommen zu pkw unsere kleine welt.
Und die kleine welt hat sich hier in der letzten ausgabe ausnahmsweise mal nicht um den brexit gedreht ich weiß gar nicht ob es mitbekommen hast schon aber.
Ich dachte ich mache mal ein ganz anderes thema und dann fiel mir aber auch während des gesprächs auf so ganz anders war das jetzt auch nichts gegen nämlich um hongkong und auch da steckt irgendwie britannien drin das scheint ja.
Ein bisschen der der schlüssel zu sein aber heute geht's wieder weiter im brexit ist jetzt ziemlich genau drei monate her dass wir die letzte sendung gemacht haben,
und wollen natürlich mal,
ein wenig zusammen fegen was ich eigentlich getan hat sich so ein dritter universum mich umher,
machen wir mal rum fragst und alle irgendwie extrem genervt sowas wie immer noch brexit und so geht auch noch.
Ja aber es gibt immer noch keine ende in sicht leider.
Genau so aber erstmal hallo hallo john.
Freue mich wieder hier zu sein danke.
Ja wie wars denn für dich in den letzten drei monaten was viel unterwegs oder.
Ja so ich habe an diversen veranstaltungen teilgenommen reden zum thema brexit gehalten in diverse
kleinen städten so überall in deutschland ich war auch in london bei dem riesen demo am neunzehnten oktober sodass wir auch ich war da so das war auch super interessant dass du vor ort anzuschauen und ja also unsere situation hat sich jetzt ein bisschen geändert weil es stehen jetzt neu waren vor uns
also das ist ein bisschen sonne neuigkeit in diese diese ganze brexit geschichte aber ja obwohl manche sind von diesem ganzen
ganze situation genervt man muss auch sagen vielleicht kriegen wir schrittweise ein bisschen klarheit.
Genau bisschen klarheit das wollen wir mal versuchen hier rein zu bekommen aber dazu müssen wir.
Unbedingt erstmal das.
Brexit machen und mal schauen was eigentlich passiert also wir haben uns ende august
hier das letzte mal getroffen es muss ja noch mal schauen wann eigentlich das ganz genau war nicht dass wir jetzt ja.
Falsches zeugnis abliefern also das war genau der zwanzigste august.
Und ja und dann ging eigentlich der reigen weiter mit einem move
von dem ich so den eindruck hatte dass er dich
ein wenig überrascht hat das war eine der option die wir zwar auch diskutiert haben aber vielleicht nicht unbedingt als die alle wahrscheinlich markiert hatten
nämlich die sogenannte pro location also
dieser schritt indem der premierminister quasi der queen sagt hier löst auch mal bitte das parlament auf oder beziehungsweise nicht lösen auf sondern beendet die session,
die session ist sozusagen nochmal so eine.
Im parlament ja so.
Der ein normaler.
Periode also nochmal also sowas zu sagen diese provokation ist normal um ein parlament ja so beenden und einen neuen parlament sozial zu beginnen also aber normalerweise hat man diese pause zwischen diesen perioden von etwa fünf oder sechs tagen
also diese große kontrovers war die boris johnson hat das für eine periode von fünf wochen,
vorgesehen also das war dann diese diese großes kontroverse so diese periode begann dann an dem am zehnten september so kurz nach unser letztes
sprich was natürlich der fall ist in großbritannien ist wir wissen ja nicht,
was sind genau die regeln also es ist nirgendwo festgeschrieben ein provokation darf so und so lange dauern oder ähm oder nicht über eine woche lang sein oder sowas in der art also wir wussten ja nicht wäre dann so diese diese location zu dieses zwangspause
überhaupt juristisch konform,
oder nicht also wir wussten es war schon ein bisschen debattiert wäre so was ein weg für boris johnson das britische unterhaus unter druck zu setzen hat sich dann für diese provokation von fünf wochen dann entschieden.
Also das war dann in den stand.
Aber warum hat er das.
Also weil der hatte.
Handeln oder ja wir sind vielleicht ein bisschen eine andere situation der hat angst,
vor dem britischen unterhaus der wusste dass er hat keine chance,
irgendeinem brexit deal durch den brötchen und haus abstimmen.
Verfügte ende august schon über keine mehrheit da in den in den brötchen mund mund und haus das bedeutet.
Es wäre für ihn den besten weg einfach,
druck auf den abgeordneten zu erhören und die anzahl an zeit für parlaments debatten zum thema brexit zu reduzieren also die waren dann die ziele für diese provokation einfach mal so zu sagen hey moment mal okay wir wollen kein
wir wollen keine debatte mehr zum thema brexit in im unterhaus weil dann die abgeordneten entdecken wie schlimm die tatsachen sind hinter hinter einem möglichen lieb.
Also rein technisch hatte er noch eine mehrheit bis zum dritten september da gab's dann diesen komischen moment wo ein abgeordneter vor den toren der philipp liegt glaube ich während.
Johnson eine rede hielt einfach aufgestanden ist.
So wir machen uns hart gewechselt ist ja es war eine sehr lustige situation ja ja aber dann kurz danach verlor er,
mehr komplett.
Oder hat kurze nach einundzwanzig abgeordneten auf seine eigene fraktion,
am neunten september rausgeschmissen
weil dieses idee das britische unterhaus unter druck zu setzen
war aus meiner sicht ein katastrophales fehler von boris johnson vorwärts zu dem fall vor dem supreme com der hat dann das britische unterhaus und du so viel druck
gesetzt dass die die abgeordneten haben sich zusammengeschlossen also viele label liberalen äh nationalisten und so weiter und einige ehemalige konservativen also die für ein brexit sind aber für ein geregeltes brexit.
Die haben dann am neunten september den sogenannten also das ben gesetz abgeschlossen trägt den namen von den hinterbänkler hillary ben
und dieses drin in diesem dieses gesetz stand nur ein brexit mit einem deal ist möglich wenn es keinen deal
bis dem neunzehnten oktober dann ist es dann erforderlich dass boris johnson es muss die eu um einen weiteren verlängerung bitte.
Also die abgeordneten unter riesen viel zeitdruck an den tagen vor diese portion also vor der pause dann unter zeitdruck dieses gesetz dann angeschlossen
also und dann dann danach am zehnten johnson dann.
Das unterhaus dann in dieses zwangspause dann geschickt.
Dieses heraus schmeißen aus der fraktion ist ja auch so eine spezifisch britische geschichte die
wir so zumindest aus der deutschen legislatur nicht kennen da ist es ja immer die entscheidung des einzelnen abgeordneten welcher fraktion man sich anschließend mit also man muss natürlich aufgenommen werden aber verlassen kann man halt selber aber so rausgeschmissen werden ist eher ungewöhnlich vor allem weil es ja jetzt hier nicht nur
das ausschließen aus der fraktion im parlament ist sondern es ja defacto auch das heraus werfen aus der partei beinhaltet.
De facto weil weil die die raus aus der fraktion sind dürfen nicht weiterhin kandidieren bei der bei der unterhaus war und diese einundzwanzig die rausgeschmissen worden sind
drei davon sind zu den gewechselt dann zähne davon sind,
nie sind nicht wieder reingekommen bei den beiden konservativen und den restlichen acht
sind wieder rein die haben so einen sogenannten so sie haben die fraktion zugehörigkeit wieder gekriegt
und dürfen dann weiterhin kandidieren
also das ist der täter lage von dieser einhunderteinundzwanzig also aber einige sehr bekannte konservativen zelten zu den diese die die die noch raus geblieben sind wie kenne klar der ehemalige finanzminister und haben auch wieder auch ein ehemalige finanzminister.
Sind deine frage
das das hängt von den parteien aber so das,
konservativen also die parteien tennis ist nicht so stark bei den konservativen das bedeutet dass der,
johnson hat er macht selbst zu entscheiden ja gehört diese person zu meine fraktion oder nicht also ja das ist sehr zentralisiert bei den konservativen.
Die formulierung los muss man vielleicht noch mal erklären also ist ja eigentlich die gibt es also gibt es einen menschen in der fraktion der sozusagen dafür da ist die mehrheiten zu sichern und der hat die peitsche.
Ja genau also unter der sorgt dann für einigkeit der fraktion also der setzt dann
die abgeordnete unterdruck damit die dann alle in die gleiche richtung dann stimmen und es hängt davon ab wie wichtig ein votum ist.
Du bist dann in so einem bedeutet ja also absolute fraktionszwang also und dann die haben dann die abgeordneten
müssen dann diese linie der fraktion dann dann zustimmen und wenn nicht
können sie dann bestrafen also die können dann raus aus der fraktion aufgeschmissen werden oder anderen dingen die kriegen kleineren büros oder die haben dann geringeren chancen um ein ministerposten irgendwann in der zukunft,
diese arten von form von taktiken sind dann von dem chef dann verwendet das ist nicht nur auf der konservativen seite so labor und die haben auch mit um um für uns,
so einigkeit zu sorgen.
Aber wir haben nicht unbedingt die gleichen strafen wenn.
Ja die haben die haben auch ähnlichen strafen also ähm es ist dass man schmeißt jemanden aus der fraktion bei laber ähm aber
die haben einen ähnlichen ähnlichen strafen wenn wenn jemand zu kontrovers ist also.
Droht dann für diese diese leute bei label so ein also das bedeutet ein dann
dass so ein ein ein neuwahl von den kandidieren nennen bestimmten wahlkreis oder das kann auch passieren bei bei lal so ist es ist seltener der farbe laber aber inzwischen taktiken können die aufhören.
Aber einundzwanzig leute rausschmeißen das ist.
Ja das war das das größte kontroverses situation vielleicht sein und.
Auch es ist auch ein bisschen eine irre.
Weil die sind alle einundzwanzig rausgeschmissen worden weil die haben den ben ein zugestimmt und irgendwann war,
etwas gegen
brexit insgesamt es war einfach nur wir wollen kein nudel also liebe eine verlängerung er sein nudel
und am brexit mit einem deal stand in dem partei in in der parteiprogramm der konservativen in in zwanzig siebzehn also diese einundzwanzig dampfzug gesagt hey moment mal wir haben die partei linie der konservativen hier sogar unterstützt also aus eine schande dass das das für für sowas äh rausgeschmissen zu werden
also das war dann eine sehr kontroverse entscheidung von von von boris johnson und das hat.
Das leben für ihn noch schwierige gemacht in die nächsten etappen also nach der provokation an also es war aus meiner sicht,
aber das seid dann taktik von boris johnson denn er hat einen einfachen weg oder auf konsens basierten weg oder ein
die ruhe weg was etwas ändern machen kann entscheidet sich in den meisten fällen für den weg also den kontroversen so aber auch auf konflikt basierten entscheidung ist was er öfters tut.
Ja die wahrnehmung von johnson war zu dem zeitpunkt wirklich so dass er dann für nudel steht so das ist ja im prinzip.
Ja nein also grober so johnson kalkül also das können wir jetzt heutzutage zum teil vergessen aber
aber damals er wollte unbedingt.
Vor dem eu-gipfel am siebzehnten oktober also der wollte einfach alle pro brexit stimmen hinter den konservativen zu vereinigen
also die die für ein nudel waren also die brexit partei wähler von von frage partei und die konservativen also alle brexit stimmen für die konservativen das war so ein tankdeckel ein und haus war wollte am fünfzehnten oktober
also und dann einfach er wolltest du die eu gib mir was für dich jetzt will und wenn ich das dann nicht kriege dann gehen wir ohne deal raus und das war das war das war den taktik dann von boris johnson.
Hatte nicht gekriegt an diesem brexit war dann verzögert das bedeutet dann das der musste da nun hat dann
musst du eine entscheidung treffen ist der für no deal oder eher für einem harten deal und und das ist wofür er sich dann entschieden hat.
Dann ende ende oktober aber für ein no deal war er nie so richtig aus meiner sicht das war einfach so ein.
Vorgehensweise um erneut druck auf die abgeordneten zu hören.
Aber es hat immerhin dazu geführt dass das dieses gespenst umging und das hat natürlich die opposition schon gestärkt das hat.
Genau genau das also leute das ist ein grund warum es aus meiner sicht des hat es hat für boris johnson nicht richtig funktioniert weil es hat die opposition parteien zu vereint und die haben dann miteinander gegen boris johnson dann gearbeitet.
Ja ich glaube bis zu dem zeitpunkt hat das dann auch schon geschafft glaube ich so fünf abstimmungen hintereinander.
So das ist wirklich eine bemerkenswerte und eine leistung die so vorher noch nicht,
gab dann passierte etwas interessantes und zwar ich weiß gar nicht wer hat die klage vorangetrieben das waren glaube ich dieselben leute die einerseits seinerzeit schon
geklagt haben dass das parlament über den brexit entscheiden muss die sind dann nach schottland gegangen.
Und haben dort den wie heißt der cord highscore.
Session dann ging es gab es einen ähnlichen fall in den englischen highscore und dann wartet mal im sind also das ist das wichtigste gericht für ganz großbritannien also praktisch
noch sogar drei aber es hat einen schottischen so gericht.
System und ein system die gerichte für england und für also und dann über diese beiden systemen steht dann den supremes cord.
Und nordirland natürlich auch.
Natürlich hat ein anderes system auch dazu also das bedeutet das diversen campagne ist haben dann dann die regierung so geklagt in,
den heiko in london in dem coaching sessions schottland,
also die haben in schottland gewonnen und in england verloren
und das landete dann vor dem britischen cord.
Das höchstes höchste gericht des landes und es war dann für.
Ein kleiner einwurf weil ich finde es ganz interessant das genauer mal angeschaut seinerzeit die entscheidung die in england dagegen fiel.
Basierte ja sozusagen auch auf einer anderen rechtsauffassung die in england herrscht im vergleich zu schottland
dass dort sozusagen ich weiß nicht ganz genau wie formulieren soll aber das im prinzip so politik und recht mehr getrennt ist und dass sozusagen diese entscheidung für die provokation naja das wäre eine politische entscheidung da haben wir nichts mit zu tun.
In schottland gibt es eine andere rechtsauffassung die sehr viel gesetz gebundener zu sein scheint die dann eben eine andere sichtweise erzeugt.
Und und auf den prinzipien passiert ist und dann kein prinzip ist das
großbritannien ist ein parlamentarisches demokratie und und weil diese fünf wochen lang provokation.
Das nur in frage stellt ist dann diese variation dann nicht.
Juristisch konform.
Also es war nicht das das gesagt hat alles ist in ordnung die haben einfach so geantwortet
diese provokation ist also das bedeutet dass wir treffen hier keine entscheidung also das ist eine art nur eine art eine politische frage also das war dann die
für diese unterschiede zwischen england und schottland
also ist einfach dann beim prime code gelandet und diese begründung von cord war einfach dass die haben so so gesagt dass diese location das
no effect.
Auswirkung und das bedeutet das britische unterhaus kann dann wieder tagen.
Und zwar gleich am nächsten tag.
Genau also das bedeutet okay und haus tag dann wieder also dann beginne dann mal wieder,
die parlaments debatten sind zum zum thema brexit also es war eine einstimmige entscheidung von dem oberste gericht.
Also die konservativen haben das deutlich kritisiert die zeitungen auch ja die sind so politisiert die die die richter die da die da sitzen aus meiner sicht
großbritannien geht so schrittweise so in richtung eine so eine normale normales modernes politisches system mit einer klare gewalt trennung wie in deutschland oder in.
Also ich fand dieses dann vollkommen normal es kann nicht der fall sein dass das.
Premiere wenn es die macht hat das parlament fünf wochen lang außer kraft zu setzen also das geht halt nicht und das ist was dann die dieses entschieden hat.
Diese entscheidung war ja auch auf mehreren ebenen wirklich bemerkenswert also zunächst einmal es waren ja dann
also es ging ja quasi durch diese entscheidung von schottland ging das ganze an den supreme nach england und dort trat dann ja ein richter gremium zusammen es waren glaube ich elf richter
davon sechs aus england und der rest setzte sich eben zusammen aus schottland wels und nordirland.
Es gab eine denke ich oder zwei.
Und es war nicht so ganz klar wie sozusagen die englischen richter sich verhalten würden es gab schon so ein bisschen die vermutung dass der supreme.
Mehrheitlich das ablehnen konnte aber dass das sozusagen ohne gegenstimmen.
Und auch noch mit so einer ganz klaren begründung kam.
Das wurde er im prinzip zu mir so von verfassung s läuten wie ich gehört habe als eine extrem wegweisende entscheidung auch für die.
Genau also jetzt jetzt haben wir zumindest grob eine idee wofür ist eine kooperation sogar gedacht,
und wofür dann nicht also es kam ein katastrophales fehler von der regierung die haben keine klare begründung gegeben
warum fünf wochen erforderlich sind.
Und das war dann im camp punkt warum ich so eine lange periode überhaupt nötig ja die müssen eine rede für die königin vorbereiten ja so das mussten jedes mal nach eine provokation braucht keine fünf wochen.
Ja es gibt normalerweise so eine so eine,
eine pause des parlaments wären die parteitage im september stattfinden ja,
klar aber normalerweise die abgeordnete stimmen selbstliebe so eine so eine pause es ist nicht verpflichtend wie johnson was getan hatte so
die regierung hatte keine gute gegen argumente es war eins von diesen fällen wo.
Niemand je in der geschichte so richtig daran geglaubt hatte könnte jemandem so.
So was überhaupt machen es ist nirgendwo schriftlich festgestellt wofür
muss man eine provokation verwenden und es ist einfach so eine so eine einfach so konvention dass man so eine provokation nur sehr kurzfristig verwendet johnson hat das so raus
es ist musste dann das prima code dann ein scheine entscheidung treffen wir wissen jetzt irgendeine provokation länger als eine woche
wird nicht zugelassen.
Das ist ja wirklich ein interessanter test also diese da haben wir auch schon paar mal drüber gesprochen die tatsache dass okay keine festgeschriebenen verfassung hat sondern immer alles so eine interpretation dessen was früher schon mal war ist.
Wird ja jetzt sozusagen durch den kurs der torres und johnson insbesondere extrem auf die prüfung gestellt weil man einfach immer wieder versucht das maximum rauszuholen.
Und sich ist eigentlich das erste mal zeigt wie gut eigentlich die kontrolle mechanismen funktioniert.
Zunächst einmal das parlament jetzt eben auch der supreme cord und man sieht irgendwie funktioniert das ganze hat ja dann auch zwei neue ikonen dieses brexit prozesses beigebracht zumindest aus der remain perspektive einerseits lady
vorsitzende was wie alt ist die.
Dir fast achtzig siebenundsiebzig oder achtundsiebzig soll so jahrelang eine bekannte richterin in großbritannien aber außer diesen engen kreisen von juristen kaum bekannt aber sie ist jetzt so richtig
bekannt geworden ja und ist irgendwie so eine heldinnen geworden für.
Eine moderne politisches system in großbritannien sind.
Er ist lustig weil es ja auch in den usa wo wir viele parallelen haben gibt es ja die auch im prinzip so 'ne ähnliche.
Ja ja ja genau genau ja ja.
Neunzig ist oder so und sich auch weiter zu sterben bis.
Ja ja genau.
Der ganze kram gelöst ist zweite ikone war dann ihre spider brut die sie getragen hat seine branche mit so einer.
Ja ja.
Bine wo viel darüber saniert wurde ob das jetzt irgendeine bedeutung hat.
Ja und viele haben diese dann in dieses beide emoji dann auf twitter verwendet und fügen das nennt.
T-shirts es gibt t-shirts.
So eine menge ganz ganz lustig ja ja.
Wir haben sich denn die medien in dem moment vorbehalten weil als es die erste abstimmung disziplin code gab quasi dem parlament die entscheidung über den brexit zugeschrieben wurde da gabs eine richtige kampagne auf und so also ganz.
Es war haben wir ähnliches gehört diesmal ja so die haben gegen den gegen den premierminister so äh gestimmt es hängt davon ab gehoben sind diese diese diese zeitung für oder,
gegen gegen die konservativen also die konservative zeitungen so daily mail,
zum beispiel die haben dann diese supreme an heftig kritisiert die die so eher links liberalen zeitungen viele guardian um mira.
Die waren natürlich auch die seite von den von den richterin des kurses also aber grob danach
obwohl es eine sehr bedeutsamen entscheidung war wir reden jetzt heutzutage nicht mehr so viel darüber so es ist jetzt,
irgendwie stiller geworden also dass diese debatte wir setzen die in diesem sprint und druck und einige konservative namen so gesagt hey moment mal so wenig gemacht haben in der zukunft
diese debatte läuft nicht weiter in großbritannien zurzeit,
aber was wir nicht natürlich nichts wissen in großbritannien ist war dieses.
Nur seit ende der neunziger es war nie so bekannt wie dem supreme in den freien staaten oder dem bundesverfassungsgericht in in deutschland also das bedeutet dass so ein ein urteil so
bekannt sein kann,
das passiert nicht so häufig in denen die britische politische geschichte also wir schauen alle den livestream annonce sondern das dinge stürzte ab und hey moment mal so wir wollen es anschauen also wir wollen
also das ist das erste mal in meinem leben dass ich fange an einer ein ergebnis sondern von den supreme.
Ja überhaupt sind die live-übertragung aus dem parlament den durchaus in konkurrenz soll der premier league.
Ja ja ja ja genau ja ja genau genau.
Wirklich mal was neues,
durfte denn das parlament wieder tagen.
Aber dann war dann erstmal so ein bisschen wieder so hängepartie weil jetzt war natürlich der ball wieder bei boris johnson denn jetzt musste er in irgendeiner form reagieren es gab da noch so ein paar winkel züge das interessante war ja das am neunten september,
nee quatsch und wir bringen gerade was durcheinander also das parlament kam erstmal wieder rein und jetzt war klar jetzt musste boris johnson was liefern es standen also im prinzip neue verhandlungen.
Ja aber aber vor dem neuen verhandlungen einmal wieder versucht ok ich will ein unter auswahl.
Hat er dann erneut versucht da kurz nach der provokation hatte nicht gekriegt so britische unterhaus hat gesagt moment mal wir wollen unbedingt dass nudel auf jeden fall von dem tisch ist dann sind wir dann bereit für ein
ohne auswahl
zu stimmen also in großbritannien man braucht normalerweise an zweiter mehrheit der abgeordneten dann dann zuhause kriegen hatte da nicht gekriegt weil sie gesagt nein
wir sind ja nicht von dem tisch ist deswegen stimmen wir gegen ein un haushalt dann dann schicken wir dagegen.
Hat ja auch damit zu tun dass dieser ben act der jetzt im prinzip die absicherung war gegen im prinzip hinfällig geworden wäre in dem moment wo es eine eine weiterführende entscheidung gegeben.
Genauso so eins okay wenn er nun haushalt vor,
dem vor geplanten austritts datum also vor dem.
Probe stattfinden könnte wer es dann doch noch möglich dass wir in großbritannien,
kriegt keine verlängerung von der eu dass großbritannien könnte dann am einunddreißigsten oktober aus der eu dann
stürzen also das war dann die vermutung boris johnson aus nach die provokation hatte wieder versucht eine aussage zu kriegen hatte nicht gekriegt weil alle oppositionsparteien haben gesagt nein moment mal
alle hinter dem band also dann gab es dann einen sehr wichtigen
richtungswechsel von von boris johnson also grob zwei wochen
vor dem austritt datum also mitte mitte oktober hat er dann so gedacht,
kriege ich nicht weil es gibt dem benni und hausfrau krieg aus meine zeitplan zumindest nicht weil die
was bleibt dann hier übrig okay dann versuche ich dann mal wieder ein deal zu kriegen
das der startete die diskussionen mit an einem treffen mit,
ich denke ich mal mein mandat da richtig ein paar tagen vor einem eu-gipfel oder eine woche vor dem eu-gipfel.
Die haben dann so gibt getroffen war da und und johnson.
Wir finden einen weg so einen geänderten deal,
also es war grob den deal was schon auf den tisch stand in,
sehen ja also schon zwei jahre her und es war dann eine,
eine deutliche änderung für wie man findet eine lösung für diese problematik an der not irische grenze als vorher vorgeschlagen.
Wollte auf keinen fall soll kontrollen an der grenze in irland,
und keine zoll kontrollen zwischen nordirland und den rest von großbritannien deswegen war dann,
ein eine zoll union zwischen die,
großbritannien und die eu möglicherweise bis zwanzig vierundzwanzig dann erforderlich also das war,
groß zusammengefasst die ursprüngliche variante von theresa may boris johnson.
Hat das dann anders gemacht danke so gesagt hey ich will dieses backstube nicht mehr.
Wir finden dann eine andere lösung der hat so eine doppelte zoll union lösung vorgeschlagen damit es
einige kontrollen gibt zwischen nordirland und den rest von großbritannien wir wissen zumindest obwohl boris johnson selbst genau den gegentor sagt dass nach dem vorgeschlagen version von boris johnson und für firmen.
Die waren von großbritannien nach nordirland liefern müssen die müssen so ein export schein
jetzt vorlegen was normalerweise in eine,
kontrollen auf waren zwischen für experten zwischen großbritannien auf von großbritannien
zu nordirland.
Das bedeutet es war dann eine wenige vorteilhafte lösung für nordirland,
für die not irische aus den von theresa may vorgeschlagene variante,
aber das war für die eu noch okay weil das war was was die eu selbst vorgeschlagen hatte vor zwei jahren
also das war dann dieses idee okay wir wir wir kehren dann zurück zu den zweitausendsiebzehner variante.
Theresa may hat das ja vor allem auch deshalb so gemacht weil sie die fdp ja noch in ihrer,
koalition hatte die also zehn sitze im unterhaus haben und dir so ein bisschen diese
hart was ich wie man die korrekt beschreiben soll aber so in den parteien spektrum der nordirakischen parteien stehen sie halt einerseits relativ weit rechts aber sind alt auch irgendwie so ein bisschen.
Aber höchstes priorität für die die op ist.
Keine trennung zwischen nordirland und den rest von großbritannien.
Und das ist ja jetzt durch johnson.
An das ist genau was und die die sind ja el sauer also die haben im moment also also wir haben jahrelang die konservativen hier unter sturz und sorry boris johnson aber sie tun genau was wir
nicht mögen und mal genau was wir nicht wollen also alle not irischen parteien.
Ja sowie sowie nationalisten sind
alle gegen dieses tier von boris johnson also und man man man hat die die das größte schwankungen in den meinungsumfrage nino lehrern gesehen in sachen brexit ist so die sind jetzt über siebzig prozent in den meinungsumfrage für einen verbleib in iran es war sechsundfünfzig prozent für einen verbleib bei dem,
bei der referendum selbst also das bedeutet das obwohl dann boris johnson unterstützung aus nordirland,
verloren hat er hat ein bisschen an unterstützung gewonnen auf dem bänken der laber parteien also weil da sorgte in diese periode so ein bisschen.
Eine brexit müdigkeit
auf die banken der label partei also einige labor haben sie gesagt okay wir haben zweitausendsiebzehn gesagt wir liefern irgendeinem brexit,
jetzt haben wir ein brexit deal auf dem tisch also dann lieber wir stimmen für dieses deal als dann weiterhin zu verhandeln also dieses obwohl
alle in nordirland fahren genervt johnson hat eine gewisse unterstützung gekriegt auf den label banken für wasser wasser da unterstützt hatte in in in brüssel also dann diese europäische rat am siebzehnten oktober hat dieses.
Dieses deal so bestätigt und dann boris johnson hat dann versucht ein letztes mal,
am neunzehnten oktober sein brexit deal durch den britischen unterhaus abstimmen zu lassen.
Bevor wir bevor wir da hinkommen weil dieses neue element
was er da ausgehandelt hat das ist ja haben sie schon angerissen aber ich finde es immer noch so ein bisschen,
während der back stop war ja sozusagen nur eine
notfall lösung deswegen gab es ja auch diesen namen für den fall dass es halt keine weitere einigung gibt es ist ja nicht.
Sie auf alle sondern es ist ja sozusagen nur wie tritt.
Britannien aus und wenn das dann stattgefunden hat dann kann über eine zukünftige lösung verhandelt werden und wenn es dann keine gibt dann gibt's diesen back stop und wenn ich das jetzt richtig sehe ist die einzige änderung das eben
eine andere notfall lösung gefunden wurde oder ist es auch schon eher eine perspektive auf eine zukünftige.
Mehr ist ein bisschen mehr auf eine perspektive für die zukunft also das bedeutet dass es könnte permanent.
Der fall sein also die diese vorgeschlagene lösung ist nicht zeitlich begrenzt also das ist was die die not ihren am meisten angst
machen er soll es dann nicht mehr das ist wir wissen ja nicht so genau weil wie das.
Die zukünftigen beziehungen werden dann natürlich auch ein einfluss hier haben und.
Eine permanente zoll union ist als zukünftige lösung nicht hundert prozent ausgeschlossen aber,
soweit wir wissen könnte diese vorgeschlagene so erneute backstube dann eine permanente lösung sein.
Das würde ja im prinzip bedeuten dass nordirland mehr oder weniger im selben zoll bereich bleibt von der eu und damit ja de facto eigentlich auch im sonstigen rechtlichen rahmen der eu verbleibt.
Tino und das könnte auch wirtschaftlich vorteilhaft für nordirland
und boris johnson nur im moment mal so das ein bisschen öl sehen also so ein deal für
england schottland ab und er sagt das ist eine krass gute dinge für die weiß von großbritannien.
Bei ihr verbleibt ja de facto.
Ja aber aber es ist lustig dass die konservativen sah ja das ist gut für nordirland und die das ist was die definitiv für england ablegen es ist es macht keinen sinn.
Das macht alles irgendwie überhaupt gar keinen sinn.
Okay dann weiß ich bei uns zumindest warum mich das hier zu zerstört das ist ja auch vor allem das,
diese neue regelung dass eine eine grenze im.
Im seegebiet also in der irischen see existiert
klingt jetzt erstmal auf den ersten blick so ja okay gut das ist ja so der typische ort wo man sowas macht wenn man sich dann aber mal anschaut wie die hafen situation eigentlich ist an der westen englischen küste also der beziehungsweise was ist das ja dann,
im wesentlichen es gibt glaube ich auch noch eine hafen.
Holly holly hat es am wichtigsten für das ganze so.
Verkehr über den irischen meer an den schottland gibt's auch eine verbindung nach direkter nordirland ja.
Genau weil wenn man sich da mal auf google anschaut wie es in hollywood so aussieht das ist so ein kleiner
da fährt man irgendwie die straße entlang da ist es so zwei drei parkplätze das war's dann aber eine ab fertigung eine customer fertigung ist doch dort.
Großes problem.
Vollkommen unrealistisch das durch also wie wie unrealistisch alle vorgeschlagene lösung.
Man muss nicht vergessen es gibt zwei sehr wichtigen punkten hier also erstens diese dass die die die konservativen hatten so ein problem mit dem bikestore war einfach mal eine begründung weil die wollten
die wollten sich nicht mit die ernsthafte probleme des brexits auseinandersetzen es war einfach so einfach mal ja
es ist wegen dem wachstum ein problem wenn es bei dem backstube nicht gäbe hätten die ein problem mit sonst was anderes.
Sehr an demokratie backstage.
Ja
Was anderes und zweitens am ende für die meisten engländer die bürger sowie auch einige konservative abgeordnete es nordirland ist für diese menschen vollkommen egal.
Also wenn man schaut in den meinungsumfrage ja lass nordirland gehen es gibt nur eine million menschen die da leben es gibt liebe sächsische millionen in den rest von großbritannien leben lassen,
einfach nordirland geben wenn es ein problem ist umso brexit lassen wollt ihr ran gehen.
Also das ist,
aus meiner sicht eine sehr gefährliche entscheidung ähm ich finde es eine schande dass diese,
diese diese thematik in nordirland so eine geringe rolle gespielt hatte vor dem.
Aber das ist gut zusammengefasst die jetzige situation.
Könnte das eigentlich meine bei nordirland reden wir vielleicht nochmal ein bisschen an mich wundert immer so ein bisschen dass die union listen in nordirland das spiel überhaupt noch mitspielen also.
Ja aber ja diese situation mit dem die op es ist.
Sehr kompliziert weil die,
die haben diesen traditionellen allianz mit theresa may
unter johnson aber die sind überhaupt nicht in der lage irgendwas eben mit mit
bin abzuschließen weil die sehen jeremy auf der seite von den nationalisten in nordirland was bedeutet obwohl die die op die hassen johnson die mögen jeremy kurbeln überhaupt nicht also
da es gibt leider die sind ja die haben so alle karten verloren gerade die nordirakischen.
Ja aber wissen sie irgendwann denke ich mir müssen ihn nicht vielleicht mal auffallen dass ihn eigentlich die republik irland eigentlich viel näher steht.
Ja aber.
Dieses chaotische system in großbritannien.
Ja aber auch es gibt.
Es gibt eine gewisse historische bündnis also das ist auch ein bisschen wie brexit also das ist das ist,
nicht logisch ja das ist das es ängste so sehr eng mit die geschichte nun irland verbunden ist mit die zwei community in nordirland verbunden also was bedeutet,
was wir sehen zumindest dass es ist nicht mit entweder.
Juni listen oder nationalisten so verbundene parteien besonders die airlines party so eine unabhängige partei des so politischen mittels in nordirland werden stärker die haben zum ersten mal zum beispiel eine europaabgeordnete gewonnen
bei der europawahl dieses jahr so was bedeutet das entweder diese so starken nationalisten von fan oder die starken ministerin von die verlieren ein bisschen und dann die und dann diese,
bisschen durch so unabhängigen und besonderes alleine party dann gefühlt aber sehr sehr langsam.
Okay aber immerhin ein trend ist zu sehen
gut jetzt musste nachdem boris johnson diesen deal diesen neuen du bist das ist neu event mit der eu ausgehandelt hat was er in gewisser hinsicht ein,
erfolg war weil
das ist eben nicht unbedingt zugetraut worden dass er da an der eu weiter noch irgendwas herausholen kann im vorfeld allerdings war die eu und natürlich auch so ein bisschen in zugzwang weil sie wollte glaube ich auf
gar keinen fall dastehen als die spielverderber sie wollten nicht diejenigen sein die jetzt schuld sind an was auch immer.
Ja genau und johnson kam zu der eu mit was schief so einen.
Das ernsthaft ist ein ernsthaftes angebot.
Versucht ein und haus war so machen habe ich nicht kriegt ich sehe keine andere lösung okay jetzt versuche ich ernsthaft ein deal hier mit der eu zu kriegen.
Ein bisschen wie theresa may das auch ernsthaft gemacht gemacht hat genau einem jahr zuvor also ich will hier bitte einen deal dieses stil kriege ich dann durch den britischen unterhaus also.
Die eu anderen siebenundzwanzig mitgliedsstaaten der eu also sie muss mich dann glauben.
Das hat sogar macron so gleich gesagt ja das johnson ist jemand mit mit mit wem man so verhandeln kann ja.
Stimmt gar nicht ja ich find's ein bisschen ungewöhnlich dass.
Die mitgliedstaaten der eu haben so dann.
Ernsthaft mit boris johnson dann so so verhandelt aber die eu hat johnson,
relativ wenig gegeben also weil in was für ein tier gekriegt hat war mehr oder weniger den deal was.
Vorgeschlagen wurde in zwanzig siebzehn
plus einige änderungen einige so abschnitte zum umwelt standards und arbeite standards in etwas schwächer geworden die befindet sich jetzt in der politische dekoration und nicht in den rechtlichen verbinde
austritts vertrag aber grob die eu hat.
Johnson etwas angeboten aber relativ wenig also die was dieses deal ist genauso gut für die eu aus der die vorherige waren variante.
Aber johnson so gesagt okay ernsthaft ich kann ich kann diese stil duschen brechen und haus am abstimmen lassen keine sorge es dann.
So nach london gegangen.
Hat mal wieder ein taktisches fehler gemacht ganz am ganz arme gehen,
sagt man man hat er wieder bestätigt liege lieber tod im garten.
As brexit nach dem einunddreißigsten oktober zu verlängern.
Aber dann das britische unterhaus sondersitzung am neunzehnten oktober hack gemacht.
Aber dann das britische unterhaus hat mal wieder gesagt hey moment mal so dann wir stimmen dieses deal nicht ab unter so ein riesen zeitung also es geht nicht also die haben dann diese sondern also das war dann eine dann dann
dann man unter noch mehr druck zu setzen dass das er muss unbedingt diese verlängerung von der eu dann verlangen hat das britische unterhaus dann am neunzehnten oktober dann dann
unterstützt also das war auch in dem gleichen tag,
wie diese riesen demonstrationen in london eine million menschen mal wieder auf der auf die straßen londons und wir standen alle da ein strömender regen haben alle auf unserem handys geguckt wie stimmt die stimmen gegen den die dich stimmen gegen johnson okay ja wir sind ja ein bisschen so sicher für ein paar ein paar wochen noch
aber so ernsthaft hier was das britische unterhaus da am neunzehnten oktober gesagt hatte ist.
Wir brauchen wer wir sind nicht für oder gegen diesen erneut erneuten deal aber was wir zumindest wollen ist.
Zeit um das alles in ruhe anzuschauen ja es gab hundertzehn seiten.
Hundertzehn seien.
Dieses protokoll sachen zum thema nordirland und hundertfünfundzwanzig zeiten erklärungen also was bedeutet.
Dieses dieses deal das auch eine haushalt so gesagt nein wir.
Wollen das halt nicht unter so viel zeit hock abstimmen müssen also sorry boris johnson sie müssen dann dieses brief nach brüssel dann schicken
und das dann hat boris johnson dann,
an den an dem tag danach dann getan hatte dieses brief aber dann ohne unterschrift sondern etwas blöde spielerei hat er dann dieses dieses brief dann äh dein geschickt.
Damit er zumindest behaupten kann er hätte es nicht unterschied.
Ja genau und dann wenn eine begründung ich sage ich schade dass dass ich diese verlängerung dann wäre dein gott zusammengefasst die eu
hat dann
bestätigt ja wir akzeptieren dieses brief und wir geben großbritannien drei monate mehr zeit wenn großbritannien früher in der lage ist aus der eu auszutreten es gibt zwei anderen zeitpunkte dann ermessen entweder am ersten dezember
oder am ersten januar kann großbritannien dann austreten wenn großbritannien schon früher bereit ist aus der eu
auszutreten also das ist fast jetzt abgeschlossen ist also großbritannien.
Kann dann juristisch noch bis denn.
Aber die eigentliche der eigentliche trick an dem neunzehnten oktober diesen samstag das parlament dann am samstag tag war ja auch glaube ich first.
War ja man hat dann.
Sondern man hat gesagt wir können erst darüber abstimmen wenn ihr,
die konkreten gesetzestext also nicht das sondern wirst roll vorliegt denn die kennen wir doch nicht obwohl es dieses,
gesetz dieses gesetzes vorschlag schon seit monaten gab weil er ja noch unter der regierung von theresa may ausgehandelt wurde aber nie.
Und ja mal wieder also es ist noch eine blöde entscheidung von von johnson weil statt einfach zu sagen okay
ich brauche die unterstützung des britischen runter hauses um dieses ding abzuschließen nein wir machen alles geheim wir veröffentlicht das in in die letzte minute und das bedeutet
alle ernsthaften demokraten sein hey moment mal also das ist
einen schritt zu viel für uns also wir sind nicht in der lage so was unter so viel zeitung abzuschließen also das.
Nicht das letzte oder das wichtigste situation als er genau das getan hat.
An hatte dann in den tagen danach dann am einundzwanzigsten oktober dieses gesetz veröffentlicht
und dann
am zweiundzwanzigsten oktober ja so wir sind jetzt so knapp vor dem austritt samstag obwohl wir wissen ja schon zu diesem zeitpunkt dass die eu bereit ist dem denn denn zu verlängern,
musst du verschieben johnson hat so gedacht ok parlamentarier ich gebe euch drei tagen nur um dieses gesetz,
zu debattieren.
Als vergleich das britische unterhaus hatte dreiunddreißig tagen seid gebraucht um den maastricht vertrag abzuschließen
und über zwanzig tagen für alle anderen eu-verträge und dieses von von dem die gesamtheit noch schwieriger für großbritannien aus dieser vorherige eu,
rege also was bedeutet denn es kann so am stimmungen am zweiundzwanzigsten oktober zuerst diese sogenannte
zweite lesung und dann eine abstimmung zu den sogenannten programm motion.
Also programm motion bedeutet wie viele tagen zeit sind erforderlich für debatten in den unterhaus also dann gewarnt
mit dreihundertneunundzwanzig zweihundertneunundneunzig stimmen und dann.
Da hat dann dieses,
dann ich erinnere mich nicht an die genauen zahlen etwa dreihundert zweiundzwanzig zu
sechs oder so stimmen also eine eine gute mehrheit war dann gegen ihm also diese abgeordneten die haben dann gesagt ok wir wollen dieses austritts vertrag debattieren,
wir sind im prinzip nicht gehen dieses austritts vertrag aber wir sind auf keinen fahrbereit das innerhalb von drei tagen abzuschließen also wir brauchen,
warum war boris johnson wollte alles abstimmen vor dem einunddreißigsten oktober wegen war was ich was ich gesagt habe liebe im gram.
Und,
er wusste dass diese dreihundertdreißig dreizig dieses dieses mehrheit auf drei neunundzwanzig dieses mehrheit von dreißig stimmen der hatte
könnte abschmecken weil es gab groß es gab diversen gruppen von menschen,
die einfach dann diversen meinungen hatten so wie zum beispiel
dieses problematik an der nordirakischen grenze ist diese lösung eine gute lösung oder dann auch laber abgeordneten die für stärkeren umwelt standards und arbeite standards in großbritannien
waren
das bedeutet das unter diese dreihundertneunundzwanzig abgeordneten die bereit waren bei der zweite lesung das abzuschneiden abzustimmen wäre es dann möglich dass alle dreihundertneunundzwanzig das noch bei der dritte lösung eine lesung sorry.
Und das ist die wichtigste dass so die endet abstimmung noch dieses deals unterstützen oder wäre es dann möglich
für die oppositionsparteien zu sagen hey moment mal so wir dieses brexit ist für arbeiter oder für britische umwelt stand.
Ein schlechtes stil also lieber das ganze ding stattdessen dann,
nicht so unterstützen am ende dieser periode sowas,
bedeutet dass das boris johnson entstanden dann vor eine entscheidung.
Es ist überhaupt möglich dass nach änderungsanträge.
Oder nicht er hat dieses kalkül dann gemacht nein,
wir haben dann keine mehrheit für einen austritts vertrag weil wenn wir das nicht unter umso zwei paaren dann am sternchen lassen dann lieber ein unterhaus war
das war dann die entscheidung von boris johnson aus meiner sicht es war wäre vielleicht eine knappe.
Entscheidungen vielleicht für den austritts vertrag wenn zum beispiel boris johnson bereit wäre
zwanzig tage zeit zu geben für ein auszuführen für für die debatte sind zu dem austritts vertrag hätte vielleicht dann ein mehrheit dann kriegen hören,
vielleicht mit einigen sitze mehrheit vielleicht.
Aber das ist typisch boris johnson statt mit dem britischen und haus zu arbeiten einen konsens fähigen weg
zu finden hatte mal wieder die andere entscheidung getroffen okay wenn wenn ich krieg mein brexit nach dem nach meinem zeitplan nicht dann lieber ein unterhaus war also ich wette dann alles,
auf dieses un haus war und das ist und das scheiterte dann mal wieder am beginn weil so gesagt hey moment mal so wann wo wann soll dieses dieses und haus war dann dann dann dann stattfinden aber die haben
dann,
ende oktober letztendlich dann die die benötigte mehrheit gekriegt,
denn für ein und haus war und das dann am zwölften dezember sodass
das erste mal seit neunzehnhundertzehn dass ein un hausmarke mitten im winter stattfinden
findet und wir wissen ja nicht was die auswirkungen dann dann sein werden aber grob es war dann einfach war boris johnson sah
hey moment mal also ich bin ja nicht sicher ob ich dann dieses ausbildungsvertrag durch den wochenausklang kriege dann lieber ein und haus war als weiterhin
so mit dem unterhaus zu kämpfen.
Diese ganze taktieren drei rund um,
neuwahlen man generell selections auf deinen brexit,
der weiterhin fleißig,
ausgeführt hast welche version bis jetzt neunundzwanzig.
Ich bin in serie die sogar die vierte serie jetzt also ab in die in die dritte serie gab's ja dreißig oder fünfunddreißig versionen ja.
Unglaublich also.
Aber in dieser dritte serie alle alle varianten die haben gesagt ein unterhaus wahl ist die höchstwerte wahrscheinlich sehr option.
Genauso so ist es jetzt auch gekommen also im prinzip hast du da richtig vorher gesagt eine weiße magischen kräfte sind hiermit bestätigt.
Es ging immer so ein bisschen hin und her zuletzt gab's ja dann auch noch eine ganz interessante diskussion zumindest bei den leuten die so ein bisschen sinnvoller über alles debattieren so nach dem motto was was wäre denn jetzt eigentlich das,
was das land wirklich bräuchte nicht was ist das wahrscheinlich so was passieren wird sondern was wäre eigentlich das sinnvollste und soweit ich das.
Interpretieren kann gab es schon so bei den gemäßigten überzeugen eigentlich kann eine neuwahl.
Die probleme nicht lösen weil diese neuwahl wird wieder komplett brexit seid nur dass sie halt nicht ein referendum ist.
Mit so gemäßigten mehrheiten im sinne von.
Die reine mehrheit entscheidet jetzt das für das eine oder das andere geht es eben durch dieses komplizierten wahlsystem über das wir schon mal gesprochen haben über das wir auch nochmal sprechen müssen.
Und es wäre eigentlich sinnvoller ein referendum vorher zu machen und zu sagen wollen wir das jetzt oder wollen wir das jetzt nicht und danach wählen wir mal unser neues parlament damit wir irgendwie auch mal wieder weitermachen können.
Aber es gibt.
Zwei antworten also entweder zuerst und haus war und dann vielleicht ein zweites referendum.
Umgekehrt.
Also aus meiner sicht.
Man man kann keine.
Komplette lösung für den brexit finden ohne ein zweites referendum aber ich verstehe auch warum ein und haus war vielleicht jetzt sinnvoll ist,
weil
zuerst ein zweites referendum zu machen mit die konservative noch im amt und die konservativen sind total gegen ein zweites referendum soll man hätte eine regierung.
Komplett gegen ein referendum und das müssen die dann ausführen das wäre aus meiner sicht ein problem ein unterhaus war.
Es kann sein dass ein und haarausfall keine lösung ist aber ein und haushalt kann auch.
Wegen eine art lösung sein.
Die konservativen gewinnen das bedeutet großbritannien kriegt ein sein brexit.
Wenn die oppositionsparteien.
Über zweihundertneunzig sitzen kriegen ja so was bedeutet das die können mehr oder weniger,
eine umgekehrt wenn die konservativen kriegen irgendwie zweihundertneunzig das bedeutet dass die oppositionsparteien kriegen über über dreihundertzwanzig sitzen.
Das bedeutet das dann großbritanniens dann auf den weg zum ein zweites referendum es gibt nur diese entscheidung die diese situation in der mitte ja wenn die konservativen gewinnen zwischen zweihundertneunzig dreihundertzwanzig sitzen.
Da ist ein weg nach vorne überhaupt nicht klar also was bedeutet dass viele leute haben sie gesagt nein also nach einem unterhaus war kriegen wir keine klarheit.
Es besteht dieses gefahr aber es könnte sein dass nach einem unterhaus war großbritannien kriegt.
Ein bisschen klarheit und.
Ja große nachteile um zuerst ein referendum zu organisieren
als zuerst ein zweites ein ein unterhaus war zu organisieren weil boris johnson kannst du zeit
nicht regieren er hat die unterstützung der nordirakischen die op verloren und er hat einen viele mitglieder von seiner seine eigene fraktion rausgeschmissen.
Ein paar sind auch wieder zurückgegangen.
Ein paar cent zinsen sind zurückgegangen aber die trainer ich nicht nicht wieder an aber ok parlamentarier
zur zeit aber aus das parlament also aufhört es und zu tagen hatte das britische unterhaus der zeit eine eine mehrheit von für für boris johnson von etwa minus dreißig sitze
achso und und es es gibt kein keine koalitions möglichkeiten in sicht gab es keine koalition mit kann filme in sich so was bedeutet
könnte nicht so einfach weiter regieren und es gibt ja natürlich andere dinge zu tun außer nur brexit denn in großbritannien.
Und er hat ja im prinzip keine einzige abstimmung durchgekommen.
Der hat dieses zweite lösung zweite lesung sorry.
Aber eine zweite lesung ist ja sozusagen auch noch nicht final.
Ist das was abgestimmt werden muss nach dieser kurzen progression phase die ist ja nochmal gab von einer woche dann hält halt die queen rede die prinzip aber ein bisschen sich ein bisschen so wie wahlprogramm anhört und,
so richtig wie ein regierungsprogramm die abstimmung darüber war aber auch eher so symbolisch.
Also da hat es überhaupt keine keine auswirkung also das bedeutet grob obwohl.
Wir könnten so ein podcast jetzt so ende dezember machen und wir haben noch keine klarheit das ist noch möglich aber wenn die konservativen gewinnen.
Großbritannien kriegt jetzt brexit mit johnson und wenn es eine mehrheit gibt für alle oppositionsparteien zusammen dann brexit wird dann weiterhin verschoben und ein zweites referendum kann im sommer nächstes jahr dann stattfinden.
Was wir auch besprochen hatten war ja die möglichkeit eine nordkonferenz wurde.
Eine regierung jetzt dreißig sitze im minus ist weil man ja mein
dass eine vertrauens abstimmung durchaus von der opposition auch gewonnen werden könnte das hat mir auch debattiert und da war ja im prinzip
das problem immer jury mit korb der halt einfach.
Nicht sonderlich populär war der hätte ja im prinzip aber auch zurückstecken können weil die nordkonferenz boot hätte a die regierung gestürzt man hätte eine übergangs regierung bilden können die dann eben in der lage wäre bestimmte dinge zu entscheiden warum,
hat das nicht stattgefunden.
Weil alle oppositions leute also die ex konservativen die liberalen.
Die shots shots nationalisten war ein bisschen pragmatischer aber so gesagt,
ich bin der chef von den haupt- oppositionspartei also was bedeutet das
ich will unbedingt übergangs premierminister werden.
Die anderen besonders die konservativen und die liberalen haben 's gesagt nein sorry der ist zu weit nach links für uns also lieber da nicht also lieber.
Einen anderen person und
die haben dann keine lösung gefunden also turbinen seine position verteidigt die liberalen ja auch und das ist dann den grundform ist nicht so ein misstrauensvotum gekommen ist weil sie können sich nicht hinter.
Irgendjemandem vereinigen also echt
ich finde es aus meiner sicht traurig also das wäre aus meiner sicht eine bessere lösung aber das ist ja parteipolitik also in großbritannien also laber laber denken ja noch dass sie
die sind ja noch eine große partei und die muss nicht unbedingt in social sachen mit anderen parteien dann groko parieren.
Aber warum haben sie denn die oppositionsparteien überhaupt auf die neuwahlen eingelassen jetzt weil es sieht ja jetzt nicht unbedingt aus wie eine klare sache für sie.
Weil die sie haben sie haben gesehen dass es gibt.
Kein weg so ein zweites referendum kurzfristig.
Zweitens was die eu sagte.
Moment mal so weiteren verlängerung gibt es ja nicht ohne.
Irgendeine art klarheit also warum müssen wir muss mir dann weiteren verzögerungen dann einfach dann mal geben.
Die schottischen nationalisten sowie die liberalen waren in einem ordentlichen stand in den meinungsumfrage am beginn der wahlkampf die haben so gedacht okay vielleicht werden wir darauf.
Jeremy hat immer so gesagt ja wir gewinnen ja ein unterhaus fahrräder jahrelang gesagt obwohl die partei ist dann in den meinungsumfrage
deutlich hinter die konservativen also der war selbst für ein ein ein ein unterhaus wahl
und die konservativen waren in den meinungsumfrage hervorragenden haben so gedacht okay dann dann lass uns dann eine auswahl äh machen damit wir dann nicht gewinnen können mit einem neuen nicht mehrheit also das bedeutet das
alle hatten halbwegs grunde,
für ein ein und hausfrau so sein wenn man schaut in den meinungsumfrage ist ein bisschen eine andere sache weil wir sind ja überhaupt nicht sicher ob laber dann so ein unterhaus wahl überhaupt gewinnen könnte.
Ok bevor wir dann mal so auf die aktuelle situation schauen müssen wir nochmal,
eine personalie besprechen nämlich eine
weitere wenn ich vielleicht sogar die ganze figur in diesem ganzen brexit prozess dieses jahres der speaker john workout der diese rolle jetzt zehn jahre.
Inne hatte und ursprünglich von den touris kam aber sich irgendwie mental
dieser struktur entfernt hat und der mit seinen ja extrem unterhaltsam beiträge und der art und weise wie er eben das parlament durch diese verhandlung geführt hat sich einen namen gemacht hat.
Der hat angekündigt seinen job zum ende oktober zu.
Kündigen hat er dann auch getan das ganze
erschienen eine reaktion darauf zu sein dass johnson angekündigt hat in seinem wahlkreis ein gegenkandidaten aufzustellen was ja und auch hier haben wir es wieder mit konventionen zu tun
sich eigentlich nicht gehört weil der speaker ist in gewisser hinsicht heilig das heißt.
Wo auch immer dieser speaker herkommt diese konsistenz.
Bleibt quasi unterrepräsentiert weil sie ja quasi die herkunft des speakers ist auch eine sehr ungewöhnliche geschichte.
Leute die davon.
Genau also die freuen sich vielleicht in gewisser hinsicht auch dass sie jetzt mal wieder repräsentiert werden können richtig,
so oder so ist er dann zurückgetreten wurde viel von der opposition geklatscht bei den touris ging so johnson hat noch eine ganz lustige abschieds rede gehalten das war 's dann irgendwie auch.
Wie bewertest du seine rolle in diesem prozess und wie bewertest du den nachfolger und welche rolle der spielen kann.
Ja so es die rolle von.
Von burger kann man nicht von dieser vorherige frage diese das ist kein misstrauensvotum gab.
Die diese fangen sie nicht voneinander zu trennen weil in eine normale situation wäre es nie erforderlich.
Dass die macht des unterhausen zu stärken gegenüber.
Die regierung in einem normalfall wurde man so eine schwache regierung einfach mal ersetzen mittels an dem ein misstrauensvotum weil kein misstrauensvotum möglich war.
War es dann erforderlich für für ein speaker die interessen des unterhausen gegenüber die interessen der regierung dann zu vertreten
und das ist dieses spiel was dann dann burger gespielt hatte mit dieser sogenannten standing oder also ein weg damit die abgeordneten könnten das parlament kalender dann kontrollieren also das ist normalerweise die macht
das unser des des regierungs.
Das parlament kalender zu kontrollieren das hat berg und dann zu geschwächt aus meiner sicht das war dann erforderlich wegen diese besondere situation wo man hatte eine regierung ohne eine mehrheit ich unterstützung,
für für die für seine brexit linie
aber auf der anderen seite keine keine unterstützung für ein misstrauensvotum also was bedeutet das denn joey burkhard sondern ein weg so hier in der mitte dann gefunden um die meinungen der abgeordneten,
zu respektieren obwohl ich nie so ein misstrauensvotum gekommen ist,
es war dann für ihn aus meiner sicht eine sehr gute entscheidung zurückzutreten weil er wusste er wäre dann bayern und haus wahl unterrichten viel druck von den konservativen.
An seine neutralität
in in in in großbritannien also es könnte für ihn dann einfach nicht weitergehen also ich finde wer das gespielt habe.
Hat war klug obwohl es.
Ungewöhnlich ist für ein ein speaker so eine große große rolle sie spielen sein nachfolger heiße lehnen sie heulen.
Ein ehemaliger.
Laber abgeordnete aus jolie also da haben die die die bürger von charlie dann keine so kalt kann bedeutsamen und hauswand mehr jetzt am zwölften dezember der ist eine ehe
ruhige typ john hat viele unterstützer gekriegt auf beiden seiten also das bedeutet der ist.
Und kann sehr unabhängig sein der hat so gesagt er unterstützt was
gemacht hat in wie burger co dann dieses standing oder vierundzwanzig verwendet hat aber er hat auch gesagt es ist sehr wichtig,
das dass das ein speaker braucht vertrauen auf beiden seiten des hart des hauses
aber nach einem unterhaus wahl wird es einfacher sein für den speaker weil die beiden parteien werden im im brexit fragen vereinte nach.
Nach so mein unterhaus war weil aller pragmatischen der konservativen sind jetzt raus,
ne also alle die so für den banner gestimmt haben ja so nur fast alle sind jetzt raus es gibt einige die noch antreten aber fast alle sind raus und auf der label seite also diese brexit laber abgeordneten.
No caroline flint tritt wieder an also das bedeutet dass die beiden parteien wenn vereinte sein in.
Fragen nach ein unterhaus war also dieses idee dass es so kontrovers so schnell wird wie es vorher der fall war bei bei dieser vorrätig legislaturperiode es wird weniger kontrovers sein in den nächsten monaten für füllen sie heute also ich hab,
eine gewisse vertrauen dass er das alles dann seriösen
klug und um und sehr fair machen kann aber er ist weniger lustig und weniger so unterhaltsam als als astro.
Das ist natürlich schade aber er war vorher auch schon stellvertretender.
Genau also der eine gewisse verantwortung also er ist ein bisschen langweilig aber durchaus okay.
Da ist man ja schon zufrieden heutzutage.
Ja ja ja genau dass er nie steht das er nicht korrupte.
Einfach verrückt also ja das ist schon eine erleichterung.
Dann kommen wir langsam mal so ein bisschen zur aktuellen situation ich würd's aber nochmal beginnt mit so einem.
Auf diese letzte parlaments periode die irgendwie außergewöhnlich war und wahrscheinlich jetzt schon geschichte geschrieben hat sowas wird so schnell nicht wieder geben.
Wobei raus ja so einiges mal komm aber so oder so war's schon interessant weil es ja in gewisser hinsicht eine.
Diese ganze brexit diskussion auch nochmal absurd um geführt hat mit control,
ja wo ja immer gesagt wurde ja unser parlament das hat ja gar keine macht und wir müssen ja aus der eu austreten damit wir das wieder haben
und tatsächlich ist ist das genau das was man irgendwie gesehen hat das parlament
hat sich die kontrolle in gewisser hinsicht zurückgeholt hat ihre ihre rolle der regierungskoalition rolle extrem gut ausgeführt muss man sagen unter dem strich.
Und es gab
diverse weitere heros dieser ganzen geschichte mir fällt vor allem da viele namen aber ich denke einer der extrem hervor getreten ist und auch einer von denen die jetzt nicht das handtuch werfen,
ist dominic rief der ja auch aus der tory partei stammt und dort rausgeschmissen wurde und auch nicht wieder reingelassen wurde und auch nicht wieder für die stories kandidieren darf der aber trotzdem als independent in seinem wahlkreis.
Antritt und wenn ich das richtig sehe haben auch die liberale demokraten gleich gesagt okay alles klar wenn du da antritt dann stellen wir auch gar keinen anderen kandidaten auf es kann also durchaus sein dass er die touris mindestens dort ärgern.
Ja ja.
Wie bewertest du sozusagen diese diese diese zeit jetzt was haben wir da gesehen weil die wahrnehmung von außen also außerhalb großbritanniens
teilweise sicherlich auch in der großteil ist
das ist ja alles chaotisch da läuft ja gar nichts mehr zusammen und das stimmt genau gewisser hinsicht was die regierungsarbeit,
trifft aber auf der anderen seite hat sich ja großbritannien auch.
Ja aber wenn wir schauen jetzt in den meinungsumfrage diese diese periode zwanzig siebzehn bis zwanzig neunzehn war eine ausnahme also in diesem hause kommend gab's es war das erste mal seit denke ich neunzehnhundert.
Neunundsiebzig als die prozentzahl
der abgeordneten von den zwei großen parteien gestiegen ist bei dieser wahl zwanzig siebzehn also diese letztes parlament war gegen die konserve team und brexit gegen remain also die die trennung war ein bisschen so partei.
Interner so wo die die brexit.
Spaltung war war nicht genau wo die parteipolitische spaltung war aber so neunzig prozent war es auch so wo die,
parteipolitische spaltung war unter abgeordneten,
was wir jetzt erleben werden ist einen weiteren schritt in in was wir in zwanzig zehn und in zwanzig fünfzehn und auch die unterhaus war und so vorgesehen haben war dann.
Eine sinkende,
prozent sollte abgegebenen stimmen für die zwei großen parteien und eine steigende prozentzahl für die kleinere parteien also schon nationalisten liberalen grünen brexit partei und und und anderen
also das bedeutet das und was was ich dann jetzt erwarte ist es wird mal wieder
so eine etwas klassische partei politisches kampf in.
Periode sein wo die parteien vereinte sind aber diversen positionen zu den großen themen dann nehmen und eine regierungsbildung oder so eine koalitionsbildung könnte dann sehr sehr schwierig sein,
was nicht normal ist in diese britische politische geschichte ist normalerweise man sieht dass die beiden parteien rücken,
in den zentrum ein ja so dass das bei blair oder bei zum beispiel die haben und hauswand gewonnen weil die rücken in den zentrum des politischen spektrums.
Das haben johnson und robin überhaupt.
Also die gehen immer noch so richtig so den extremen also
die konservativen sind jetzt eine sehr harten brexit partei die haben alle pragmatischen rausgeschmissen also die sind
so harte brexit partei wie die von von zwanzig fünfzehn auf der label seite laber hat einige fragen martin rausgeschmissen und die sind einfach so drehen wieder der stellvertretender partei.
Tritt nicht an und wenn man
kann den kandidaten gewinnen die soll so leer gewordenen sitzen oder oder auto treten denn dafür lebe an es sind leute die nasen also das
bedeutet dass man sieht ja in nicht brexit sachen so eine riesen lücke in der mitte des spektrums.
Also das ist was dann so entstanden ist während diese diese diese letzte letzte zeit man muss auch sagen dass
unter mai und unten jetzt unter johnson die macht des premierminister so starke
geworden ist also in seinen kabinett hat zurzeit johnson keine ernsthafte gegen gegner
also die sind aller hinter ihm das bedeutet dass.
Man hat so eine gewisse sos zentralismus das wie man regiert in großbritannien erlebt in den letzten in den letzten paar jahren.
Ja also die sind die die die dinge die man.
Gesehen hat in den letzten jahren habe aber ich denke wenn wir blicken zurück wir werden dann mal sehen dass diese partei parlament zwanzig siebzehn bis zwanzig neunzehn,
diese kommende und haus wahl sieht obwohl es komisch klingt sieht ähnlich aus erst zwanzig fünfzehn zwanzig siebzehn.
Was heißt das jetzt für die nächste wahl wie ist jetzt das parteiensystem.
Aufgestellt über touris und leben jetzt schon viel gesprochen und ich glaube die positionierung ist relativ klar ich vermute mal leber wird versuchen ähnlich wie zwanzig siebzehn.
Andere themen auch auf die agenda zu setzen und das brexit thema nicht so sehr in den vordergrund zu spielen auch wenn sie sich dazu natürlich in irgendeiner form verhalten müssen aber ich glaube die ganze zeit
von leben in den letzten jahren war halt dadurch geprägt dass ich diese klare haltung so nicht finden konnten einerseits weil sie innerhalb der partei zerstritten waren und
einfach auch das was gekommen vorgeschlagen hat einfach windelweich weil man nie so genau wusste was
was willst du jetzt wisst ihr es eigentlich brexit willst du es nicht daran hat sich glaube ich relativ wenig geändert.
Jetzt stellt sich natürlich die frage die politische mitte die jetzt von den großen parteien nicht besetzt wird.
Kann die von einer anderen partei und da fällt mir eigentlich nur die liberale demokraten ein wirklich gefüllt werden.
Zuerst eine kurze zusammenfassung von die brexit positionen von diversen parteien.
Laber die position der liebe partei hat sich ein bisschen geändert seit der parteitag mitte september,
laber ist jetzt offiziell für ein zweites referendum.
Obwohl nicht offiziell für einen verbleib aber das bedeutet dass man hat eine gewisse sicherheit das ist ein weg so ein zweites referendum also das ist ausreichend für die meisten leute,
die liberalen sind für also die einseitige rucksack des artikel fünfzig briefe so so alles zu stoppen aber können ein zweites referendum akzeptieren die grünen sind für ein zweites referendum die schottischen nationalisten ja auch so wie auch die nationalisten.
Die konservativen sind für den deal von boris johnson und die brexit partei ist für jetzt raus ohne deal,
also das bedeutet man eine gewisse klarheit von wo stehen dann die diversen parteien in sachen brexit.
Das problem natürlich es nicht wo stehen die parteien sondern ist alles wegen dem britischen,
wahlsystem es heißt first paste post ist um ein mehrheit war system das bedeutet das
wer dann in einem wahlkreis mehr stimme.
Gewinnt dann dieses wahlkreis es ist dann ein problem.
Nehmen wir ein beispiel von sagen wir kensington in in london zurzeit ein.
Laber wahlkreis hat leben zum ersten mal in der geschichte zwanzig siebzehn gewonnen,
laber damals ja die wanne knapp vor die konservativen.
Mit den mit den liberalen weiter hinter auf dem dritten platz die frage ist dann.
In welche richtung muss man dann dieses mal dann wählen,
in den meinungsumfrage sind die liberalen jetzt vor laber in so ein wahlkreis.
Aber laber hat dieses wahlkreis gewonnen zwanzig siebzehn also wechselt man dann auf das,
dass alle laber wählenden von zwanzig siebzehn weiterhin leber wählen oder nicht
oder wenn man schaut in seinem wahlkreis ist ein relativ reiches wahlkreis im zentrum von
auch mehrheitlich für den verbleib haben die burger da gestimmt bei der bei der bei der referendum es ist dann eine bessere wahl da lieber zu wählen
ja und wie treffe man so eine entscheidung in so einem wahlkreis das bedeutet es ist dann keine einfache entscheidung also leute die dann für einen verbleib sind sagen hey moment mal so laber ist eher fan verbleib die liberalen auch aber wir wollen unbedingt dass die konservativen nicht gewinnen also wie machen wir das was wir nennen
taktisch.
Das auch nichts neues ne.
Ja genau also aber das ist dann noch wichtiger dieses mal,
als vorher weil alle alle parteien wollen etwas machen.
Um die konservativen zu verhindern
ach so ich bin mitten in eine sehr tief gehende analyse wie kann das dann funktionieren nach dem jetzigen stand in den sechshundert zweiunddreißig wahlkreisen in england schottland ausnahme sechshundert zweiunddreißig wahlkreis in england schottland es ist ja klar,
wie man zu voting verwenden muss in sechshundert davon.
Es sind nach meiner schätzungen eines davon ist geld ist gerade dieses dieses beispiel was ich gerade benannt habe kensington aber in sechshundert anderen ist ja klar wie man wählen,
muss wenn man brexit verhindern will.
In dieser anderen dreißig ist es eine sehr komplizierte sache du hast vorher beckens wieder so das ist dieses wahlkreis und von dominik zitiert also wo
unabhängigen kandidaten antreten das bedeutet dann irgendwo ist unabhängigen kandidieren gibt.
Es ist eine etwas schwierige sache oder wo die label kandidieren brexit sind es ist etwas komplizierter da auch aber grob zusammengefasst obwohl,
ich mag das aus taktik nicht ich finde.
So ein taktik outing mussten wir unbedingt machen weil.
Es gibt keine andere option also ich werde auch genau das gleiche machen also wo ich wo ich wähle in großbritannien und im osten da label gewonnen das letzte mal.
Mit die konservativen auf den zweiten rang und die anderen parteien weiterhin so also ich würde selbst sehr gerne grün wählen,
aber da können theoretisch ist so sehr klares ergebnis vielleicht das letzte mal aber da ist es mich so gefährlich für für die grünen zu wählen ich muss dann label wählen weil ich will unbedingt die konservativen stop stoppen also das ist oder dieses artet das so vorgehensweise
was wäre zumindest wissen nach dem meinungsumfrage ist diese debatte um taktisches voting hat schon gestartet
wir haben wo es meinungsumfrage in einzelnen wahlkreisen gibt,
da haben wir enormen vorsprung für liberalen gesehen in wahlkreisen wo laber überhaupt nicht gewinnen kann zum beispiel so dass es im wahlkreis von dominik der jetzige
der jetzige außen.
Also hier war laber auf dem zweiten platz in äh in zwanzig siebzehn aber dann die liberalen knapp dahinter
wenn man schaut jetzt in den meinungsumfrage laber hat fünfzehn prozentpunkte verloren.
Und die haben zwanzig prozent gewonnen also das bedeutet in so ein wahlkreis so london
und sehr reich da lohnt es sich dann für für die liberalen zu wählen
in manchen anderen wahlkreisen
laber gegen die konservativen aber dann im not englischen städte
oder mehrheitlich für liebe oder oder ländlichen gebieten da hat es noch sehen noch für laber zu wählen also die sind dann die arten von entscheidungen die die wähler in großbritannien dann dann treffen müssen
bei der bei der letzte war haben etwa fünf millionen menschen so tätig ting gemacht.
Es gibt ja diverse online tool sie dann die eltern erklären wie es dann gehen kann wie man dann in so einem wahlkreis abstimmen muss.
United.
Also die sind die die die vier tools die bienen in einige wahlkreise diversen ergebnissen.
Aber ich werde selbst in den nächsten tagen dann meine eigene auswertung machen um einfach mal eine prognose so geben okay das sind die beste wege um einfach dann die.
Brexit kandidieren in alle möglichen wahlkreisen einfach zu stoppen.
Jetzt ist natürlich das tägliche voting nicht nur eine sache der fraktion sondern das dürfte sich auch,
der lief seite
gesprochen haben und hier ist ja dann insbesondere die position der brexit party ganz interessant
einerseits drohte natürlich die pure existenz der brexit party ja wir erinnern uns bei der europawahl extrem gut abgeschnitten hat
sozusagen schon das ganze voting potenzial der tori party durcheinander zu bringen und das tut sie in gewisser hinsicht immer noch
gestern kam glaube ich die meldung dass verarscht ist angekündigt hat.
Überall da wo es klar ist dass die touris dort
tag sind oder letzte mal.
Das letzte mal gewonnen haben also die dreihundertsiebzehn,
wahlkreisen wo die konservativen das letzte mal gewonnen haben treten jetzt brexit party kandidatinnen nicht mehr an ja aber
es gibt ja hier in hagen weil warum diese dreihundertsiebzehn,
ja es ist ein bisschen eine ungewöhnliche entscheidung warum nicht wo leber das letzte mal gewonnen hat aber die konservativen knapp dahinter sind ja das wäre
auch dann sinnvoll also aussicht touris oder so wir wissen ja nicht
warum genau dieses in diese entscheidung getroffen hat also es muss irgendwas hinter den kulissen geben gegen meine begründung
das hilft ja natürlich dann die konservativen in knappen wahlkreisen wo die konservativen zwanzig siebzehn nach vorne form waren also besonders zum beispiel ihren dank ins meer eine ehemalige konservative parteichef ist in frankfurt und das ist ein ein ein london wahlkreis.
Der hat dann knapp vor laber hatte
unter dreitausend stimmen mehr als label gekriegt das letzte mal
und die anderen parteien waren da nirgendwo also das bedeutet das ist dann vorteilhaft für jemand wie ihn dann ging's mir ging dass die dass die brexit
partei da nicht antritt aber zum beispiel wenn man schaut nach great b zum beispiel da ist wo laber gewonnen hat
das letzte mal ja aber da relativ knapp vor den konservativen
und wenn man schaut in great da und haus war zwanzig fünfzehn da hatten sogar die party zwanzig fünfzehn zwanzig prozent ab der gegeben stimmen gekriegt zwanzig fünfzehn,
also was bedeutet es wenn brexit party noch antritt dann label wird dieses wahlkreis dann weithin gewinnen wenn die dani stand reden dann sind die chancen für die konservativen noch höher
weil obwohl ich kann ein bisschen widerspruch ist weil es gibt einige labert wählen.
Grob wir wissen grob zusammengefasst wenn brexit partei nicht antritt.
Die hälfte diese wähler gehen nicht zu irgendeinem anderen partei die gehen zur wahl nicht die hälfte sind diese stimmen sind dann verloren,
von den übrigen fünfzig prozent fünf sechste gehen zu den konservativen und ein sexuell zu der laber partei.
Er soll das bedeutet dass in einem wahlkreis wie great es ist dann vorteilhaft für laber
wenn die wenn die brexit partei antritt weil die nehmen mehr stimmen von den konservativen hast du jeweils von label nehmen,
also was bedeutet das es wäre dann für lebe in einem wahlkreis vorteilhaft wenn.
Brexit party weithin kandidiert und wenn die nicht weiterhin kandidieren das wird dann die konservativen dann helfen.
Aber das muss doch auch national verarscht wissen.
Ja genau aber das ist dann was wir da nicht wissen ist warum hat er dann,
diese entscheidung für diese dreihundertsiebzehn wahlkreisen dann getroffen statt einfach mal zu sagen okay wir treten nicht an ihnen sagen mir
hundert wahlkreisen wo es am knapsen war zwischen die konservativen und laber ja ich verstehe diese entscheidung nicht.
Es macht keinen sinn es macht es muss irgendeine begründung ja geben irgendwo aber.
Es ist ja nicht klar warum er genau diese entscheidung getroffen hat.
Na die verschwörungstheorie die gänge gesagt glaube ich dann schon verarscht hat gar kein interesse daran ist es zum brexit kommt weil das ja sein dauerthema ist und er muss ja irgendwie sein.
Ja ja ja genau also ist oft als begründung und er will irgendwie hab ich so relevant sein.
Vielleicht in den kommenden tagen und wochen werden wir mehr herausfinden.
Man kann ja nicht nur kein speaker werden wenn man seinen wahlkreis nicht gewinnt sondern man kann ja auch nicht premierminister werden wie steht es denn um bewusst schon wahlkreis steht er überhaupt schon fest.
Genau also der es gab ja monatelang gerüchte dass er in nicht an wo er zurzeit dann dem.
Es war relativ gut für ihn dort das letzte mal hat ein vorsprung von etwa fünftausend sitze aber man muss nicht vergessen dass es gibt ein.
Sorry.
Prozentual muss man das sagen also zwanzig siebzehn am fünfzig knapp fünfzig komma acht prozent für konservativ gewählt aber vierzig prozent für labor.
Ja also.
Aus meiner sicht die obwohl die liberalen sind jetzt da sehr aktiv ich find's wenn die das die beste wahl gegen boris johnson ist dann,
da label zu stimmen aber sobald wir wissen der herz zeit bis donnerstag sondern zwei tagen noch zeit.
Sich einen anderen wahlkreis auszusuchen boris johnson wenn er dann.
Sicher sein will dass es ein wahlkreis noch so behalten kann aus meiner sicht das wäre ein katastrophe eine katastrophale entscheidung jetzt zu wechseln weil das wird dann die konservative partei total
erschrecken wenn er nicht sicher ist dass die konservativen in
ja das bedeutet irgendwas läuft schief mit dem wahlkampf der konservativen und das das das das wird dann eine große vertiefen also ich gehe dann davon aus dass er tritt dann noch an und er wird dann knapp gewinnen weil die konservativen enorm viel,
da investieren damit er dann dann gewinnen kann der kandidat der label partei ist in diesem wahlkreis gibt's geboren hat da studiert
aber der ist im relativ jung relativ unerfahren und hat
er war auch in diese so antisemitismus problematik der partei war auch impliziert also was bedeutet das ist vielleicht schwierig für viele für den laber kandidat da so so stimmen also was bedeutet wir können ja hoffen dass er der das halt da verliert
aber ich vermute die chancen sind sehr sehr gering dass er da verliert leider es wäre sehr lustig.
Die rolle der kleinen parteien geht er hier so ein bisschen,
unter also
insbesondere die grünen leiden natürlich am meisten unter diesem wahlsystem weil ich denke das potenzial für die grüne partei ist eigentlich sehr viel größer in großbritannien das hat man ja auch bei der europawahl gesehen.
Genau stimmt.
Und die caroline lucas die chefin der grünen die auch den einzigen p stellt weil sie da in ihren sitz schon lange gut halten kann das ist ja so ein grünes.
Hochburg.
Super zentrum.
Das für dich in kreuzberg.
Die hat sich ja hat sich ja auch sehr positiv hervorgetan in der ganzen brexit diskussion.
Ja ja.
Jetzt steht sie natürlich so ein bisschen in der situation überall konzession machen zu müssen und zu sagen ja okay ihr dürft uns nicht wählen damit remain kommt wie gehen sie damit um.
Also die die parteien also die liberalen grünen
komm her so die bayerischen anzulassen also die haben dann einen sogenannten heißt das am abgeschlossen und das bedeutet in einige wahlkreisen die liberalen treten die standen wo die mal sondern irgendwann mal in der zukunft eine chance immer nur einen
ein wahlkreis gewinnen und einige anderen aber ich bin ja versichert dass die grünen werden
nur mal wieder nur noch ein wahlkreis dann gewinnen.
Leidet die chancen sind denn da sehr sehr sehr sehr gering für die grünen ist ja schade
ja so das ist das wahlkreis dann von von karl also und wird weiterhin von den grünen gewonnen also ohne großen sorgen aber außerdem es gibt keine.
Gibt es einige interessanten entwicklungen also da in zwei wahlkreisen besonders.
Breaking bad und mund da treten die diva lischen nationalisten nicht an und da haben dann die liberalen so ein an ein freies rennen ja und die haben die haben dieses wahlkreis ja schon.
Das war zwanzig siebzehn die haben bein und hier haben bei nachfahren zwanzig neunzehn dieses wahlkreis gewonnen und dann in vier anderen wahlkreisen in die notwehr schnecke von dem
von wales da treten die liberale nicht an,
um das beste ermögliche so lauf sowieso geben also war das könnte ein unterschied von bis sechs sechs,
wahlkreisen auswirkungen da haben in in in wels also das da hat es schon eine eine bedeutung.
Wo sonst tutorials gewonnen hat.
Ja genau.
Schon eine menge.
Oder oder so ein zwanzig siebzehn gegenüber namen ja.
Oder zumindest knapp ist damit man sicher sein will dass diese wahlkreisen gern gehen nicht zu den wechsel nicht zu den konservativen.
Die rolle des gottes national party erscheint mir ja so den ist.
England in gewisser hinsicht ja egal die dritten der ehe nirgendwo an in schottland sieht's meiner meinung nach so aus als ob sie die chance haben wirklich jeden möglichen sitz.
Ja die die werden nicht alle sitzen gewinnen also die haben sechsundfünfzig von neunundvierzig gewonnen den spannend sitzenden zwanzig fünfzehn so ein unglaubliches ergebnis werden die nicht mal wieder kriegen.
Ne also es gibt noch ein bisschen problematisch dann noch weil diese diese brexit frage ist noch mit dieser unabhängigkeit frage so so eng verbunden,
und es gibt einige wahlkreisen die leibe gewonnen hat das letzte mal und liberalen auch älter darunter windsor die parteichefin der der.
Der lebt.
Dieser schottland.
Ja ja sie sind denke ich in soweit ich weiß dann dann.
Das bedeutet das in alle netze stimmt nicht sorry da habe ich nicht recht.
Es ist eine maß muss einen anderen shots schön wahlkreis sein die.
Da wir sind jetzt fast sich und nicht fasse ich also in alle zwölf.
Wahlkreisen in schottland wo die konservativen gewonnen haben das letzte mal wann war die mp auf den zweiten platz.
Das bedeutet dass eine vielen von diesel schottischen konservativen paragraphen gehen dann verloren und wenn von der ep gewonnen
die anderen also die die treten die die machen keinen großen versuchen,
wahlkreisen von laber oder von die liberalen zu gewinnen aber einige,
könnten ja dann wechseln schottland ist das einzige
teil großbritanniens wo man orten hart mit zwei
parteien auf den ersten zwei rängen also in manchen orten ist es da man kann dann einfach frei entscheiden ja will ich denn es sind oder label oder sowas in der art
ohne ein großes gefahr dass die konservativen ja da gewinnen können also ich gehe davon aus dass die npd gewinnen ja zwischen vierzig und fünfzig von den,
von den neunundfünfzig wahlkreis in schottland das war ein richtig gutes ergebnis aber nicht genauso gut wie das ergebnis in zwanzig fünfzehn.
Okay aber ist es da nicht auch so ein bisschen auch schon so eine vor abstimmung über die möglichkeit eines schottischen referendums.
Ja obwohl das bis jetzt keine große auswirkung härte auf dem auf das wahlkampf insgesamt also weil die post schon gesagt ja also
ich will kein zweites volksabstimmung in schottland ich will kein zweites volksabstimmung zum thema brexit laber hat schon gesagt okay wir wollen ein zweites brexit referendum und irgendwann mal vielleicht auch ein zweites referendum in schottland,
sehen wir halt mal aber ja das wird eine große auswirkung haben in schottland.
Aber da müssen auch die nationalisten,
vorsichtig sein weil die haben ja eigentlich natürlich dass wenn ein hartes an stattfindet.
Das miteinander auch eine auswirkung auf schottland haben weil einen unabhängigen schottland.
Die dann die eu beitreten will will keine harte grenze zwischen schottland england so das bedeutet dass die müssen diese fragen ein bisschen verbinden aber nicht all zu viel also die wollen einfach mal das.
Aber gegen unabhängigkeit schotten auch.
Die wählen können also ein praktisches votum gegen den brexit ja so ein bisschen schwierig spiel
also das ist was die was die dann gerade versuchen die liberale natürlich in schottland also die haben eine klare position gegen brexit und für den
und gegen die unabhängigkeit also was ist dann eine gewisse einfaches ding bald haben für die liberalen dazu machen aber außer in einige wahlkreise die sind ja nicht unbedingt so stark in schottland also nur in den zentrum belt und nicht wo es so in vorher so industrie gab also in am rande von den zwei großstädten in schottland,
haben die die liberale da eine stärke.
Jetzt ist es natürlich also nichts war glaube ich so schwer oder ist so schwer vorherzusagen sehen wie der ausgang dieser wahl aus dem schon hier genannten gründen das wahlsystem die unberechtigt bekannt wie die leute eigentlich stehen wie sehr sie
jetzt über den brexit abstimmen wie sehr sie über andere themen
abstimmen man im dezember was weiß ich wenn deine grippewelle über.
Italien zieht und irgendwie der nationalelf service wieder im mittelpunkt steht also es gibt eine ganze menge senario wo man sich vorstellen kann wie das wie das vorherrschende thema schnell beeinflusst ist mal ganz
abgesehen von dem üblichen kräfte spiel der außenpolitik und sonstiger
welt ereignisse und trump und was nicht alles das lässt sich sicherlich alles nicht so richtig machen aber trotzdem
ist ja in gewisser hinsicht absehbar welche konstellationen sich ergeben.
Die eine konstellation ist klar in dem moment wo die tores eine absolute mehrheit im parlament erhalten.
Dann würde es schwierig werden.
Ja ja also das bedeutet brexit findet am einunddreißigsten januar statt
mit dem deal dann die nächsten fragen sind dann wie wie gehen dann die zukünftigen handlungen dann weiter und ob dann die vorgesehenen übergangs periode also bis ende zwanzig zwanzig
ähm ob das ausreichend ist
ähm für eure mein deal abzuschließen wir gehen davon aus dass das dann nicht dass ich dann die debatte muss dann diese diese übrigens periode dann verlängert werden aber dann das bedeutet dass großbritannien ist dann auf so,
die die harten verhandlungen dann konzentriert aber brexit dann findet am einunddreißigsten januar start grob
ja die die großen spannungen sind dann für einen anderen tag es kommt dann zu den zukunft beziehungen und die konservativen dann können dann weiterhin regieren
bis gehen wir dann davon aus bis zwanzig vierundzwanzig so das ist die vermutung.
Je nachdem wie groß das chaos wird was durch.
Ja i zuerst nicht ähm also ein großes chaos könnte
danach dann passieren aber man muss auch nicht vergessen dass die konservativen deutlich vereinigte sein dieses mal als a zwanzig siebzehn
also ich gehe davon aus dass wenn die wenn die verfügen über eine mehrheit dass die ohne großen problemen ein jahr lang oder so regieren können.
Okay und weiter müssen wir auch nicht in die zukunft schauen.
Ja genau dann.
Chaos wird es ja geben wenn die konservativen gewinnen ja zwischen zweihundertneunzig dreiundzwanzig sitzen also das bedeutet in alles von.
Nicht alleine regieren.
Also.
Sorry ich fasse das wieder zusammen man man hat die achtzehn sitz aus nordirland ja und sage mir sieben bis acht davon sind die nehmen diese diese sitzen dann nicht.
Das ist das größte problem ist in welche richtung stimmt die fdp ja so die sind nicht bereit boris johnson brexit unterstützen haben die sind auch nicht bereit premierminister unterstützen das bedeutet das.
Ist doch die frage wie stark wird überhaupt die op also.
Ja die wir vermuten die gewinnen ja zwischen sieben und zehn sitzen also da gibt 's auch keinen großen unterschiede ja aber.
Es sei denn dieser airlines.
Ja die werden ja nur ein und das ein oder zwei ja gewinnen können leider weil weil die sind nur die anderen so getrennt.
Also die chaotischen situation sind die storys können nicht regieren.
Und die opposition sagt die englisch schottischen und politischen oppositionsparteien können auch nicht regieren die felgen verfügen über keine mehrheit weil man hat diese sachen wie sieben bis zehn die leute dein da in der mitte.
Also das ist so die katastrophal situation also wie kann man dann überhaupt
dann weiterhin regieren entweder die unterstützt johnson aber verlangen von ihm eine änderung des brexit muss dann mal wieder in einer poste moment mal was ich da nicht
oder die liberalen schließen eine koalitionsvertrag mit die konservativen dann abend sein okay wer regieren mit euch nur wenn ein zweites referendum stattfindet aber ich.
Kann das
kaum vorstellen dass sowas möglich wäre war johnson so ein ähm ähm so eine lösung vollkommen ab aber dann
dann keine mehrheit für seinen brexit also den weg nach vorne ist dann vollkommen unklar also diese in der mitte keine klare mehrheiten situation.
Dann geht das ganze drama so wie wir's jetzt kennen noch zwei jahre.
Total und noch schwieriger zu lösen als jetzt und und
und großbritannien unter zeitdruck von die neue brexit deadline chaos und dann wenn die wenn
die konservativen gewinnen ja
und zweihundertneunzig sitzen das bedeutet das insgesamt die oppositionsparteien also laber liberalen community gold gewinnen genug sitze um halbwegs zu regieren
das bedeutet ich vermute da die die die höchstwerte wahrscheinlich zur lösung wäre eine minderheitsregierung der label partei
nur unterstutz von die anderen parteien weil die bringen großbritannien bis zu einem zweiten referendum dann hin ja sonst keine formelle koalition.
Oder vielleicht eine koalition zwischen shots nationalisten und laber,
vielleicht das ist wahrscheinlich zwischen die liberalen und und und laber dann ein weg dann ist mein zweites referendum,
dann relativ klar grobe zusammengefasst auf meine suppe runden brexit die chancen ja an das sind es ist sehr schwierig weil die meinungsumfrage schwanken.
Enorm zurzeit die chancen auf meinen brexit gramm sind so zeit grob zusammengefasst für ein.
Brexit mit einem deal ja ist bei dreiundsechzig prozent weil das ist was die welt börsen zurzeit denken die chancen sind dass die konservativen verfügen über
ausreichend sitze um dann reagieren zu können also keine lösung in sicht
zwölf prozent und ein zweites referendum findet dann startet so das bedeutet das oppositionsparteien dann gewinnen dann an an an unterstützung fünfundzwanzig prozent
also diese entscheidung von niko frage von gestern ist nicht da rein in den jetzigen brexit-drama soll ich vermute dann dass die chancen werden nur hören,
dass es kommen dann so ein brexit am einunddreißigsten januar es wird dann noch hören
was wir erwarten können nach dieser erfahrung von zwanzig siebzehn ist die meinungsumfrage wenn tendenziell besser für label
während den wahlkampf also was bedeutet das die chance das label gewinnt oder zumindest die sitzen gut
verteidigt wenn dann etwas höher und die chancen dass viele wähler machen eine entscheidung für crowdfunding wenn auch noch hört
und einfach mal leute wenn da mal sagen okay ich muss unbedingt laber unterstützen weil die alternative ist noch schlechter also das bedeutet.
Aus meiner sicht das ist vielleicht ein bisschen zu negativ zurzeit aber das ist jetzt die situation mit dem jetzigen meinungsumfrage also sehr so aus als ob,
großbritannien doch noch austreten am einunddreißigsten januar.
Jetzt könnte er die öffentliche meinung auch.
Noch sich dadurch ändern dass die aktuell
herum fliegenden bestechung vorwürfe gegen boris johnson und auch die im raum schwebende russland
connection vielleicht eine rolle hat was was ist denn da eigentlich bekannt und was hat es mit diesem nicht veröffentlichten.
Ist ja eine schwierige frage ähm.
Die
auch die oppositionsparteien haben keine große interesse an diese diese dieses bericht der regierung zum thema einfluss aus russland auf den zwanzig sechs in der referendum und die regierung hat einfach gesagt ja wir publizieren dieses bericht nach dem.
Nach dem nach dem mund haus wahl das ist kein kernthema der wahlkampf geworden,
auch journalisten hatten nicht so eine überragende interesse an dieses thema oder auch das passt zu den brötchen selbstwert nicht ja wir briten wir sind nicht korrupte menschen
ja so einfach mal also es lohnt sich nicht sowas untersuchen also ich finde das.
Vollkommen unverantwortlich aber aus meiner sicht.
Ich verstehe auch nicht warum haben die konservativen das nicht einfach so publiziert also die konservativen haben so eine reihe von skandalen gehabt also boris johnson diese diese
verrückte rede gehalten in nordirland vor ein paar tagen also auch die super
getrunken war anscheinend hast du diese rede gehalten hatte er hat seinen eigenen brexit nicht verstanden aber das war so überall auf twitter aber das erschien kaum kaum irgendwo in den in dem so sage ich die traditionellen medien das,
boris johnson kante nicht was in seinem eigenen brexit stillstand aber die oppositionsparteien setzen ihm unter nicht so viel druck also das bedeutet dass irgendwie mal ich hab den eindruck dass dieses wahlkampf hat
auch nicht
unbedingt so richtig stark gefunden also niemand setzt boris johnson unterrichte ich viel druck also irgendwie da hatte so vieles gandalf hinter sehe ich das.
Irgendwie der ist noch ein skandal hinzu.
Keine auswirkung irgendwie so ein bisschen trump wie mit trump,
in franken starten und weil ich bin der will immer über seinen eigenen sachen reden und nicht über seinen gegnerin oder es keine,
position
politiker im wahrsten sinne des wortes also irgendwie die meinungsumfrage haben sich kaum geändert seit dem beginn der wahlkampf also das
bedeutet ich.
Nicht sicher inwiefern diese diversen skandalen und problemen überhaupt eine auswirkung haben und wir haben auch eine reihe von
von von kandidieren werden die die dann schon zurücktreten mussten nicht
konrad rassistische oder oder oder eure sexistische kandidat für die konservativen da ist nicht angetreten an kandidat der laber partei musste musste zurück
treten ein anderer kandidat in in in entweder morgen der konservativen ist unter so sexuelle belastung so untersuchungen und weiter an.
Man hat den eindruck dass normalen standards von einem so normales politisches vorhanden von dem von kandidieren.
Irgendwie hier nicht also irgendwie.
Ich find's schwierig zu verstehen zur zeit was könnte ein auswirkungen haben
auf dieses wahlkampf weil alles was wir gesehen haben das war so 'ne riesen reihe von skandal in den letzten sag ich sieben tagen aber hast du bis jetzt praktisch keine auswirkungen auf das auf die debatte.
Weil es nicht in den medien durchschnitt oder was die leute nicht interessiert.
Ein bisschen von dem von diese beiden sachen weil einfach die sind es ist ja die sind ja alle korrupt
laber hab dieses problem mit den antisemitismus problematik von von von kurvig die konservativen haben so einen anderen antimuslimischen problem wir wissen ja schön dass das
boris johnson keine fähre oder oder vertrauenswürdig mensch ist also das ist also.
Es ist irgendwie das dass die die wähle denken ja wir müssen einfach so zwischen pest und cholera dann dann entscheiden auch die liberalen kommen nicht besonders gut rüber also weil ich finde dass das das.
Dass die
winsen sie will dann ernst genommen werden aber statt alles auf brexit zu fokussieren sie versucht eine sehr personalisiertes wahlkampf zu führen die wir nennen das joyce windsor franzosen diese partei gehört nicht also es ist irgendwie bitte einfach den kompletten fokus auf,
fragen das wäre aus meiner sicht die lieblings lösung also das bedeutet dass keine parteien machen guten wahlkämpfe aus außerdem,
ja so aber alle anderen es.
Chaos und die so normales politisches professionalisieren moos fehlt,
bye bye bei viele viele parteien.
Ein label kandidatin in barcelona hat
ganz versteinerte arte abgeordnete zurückgetreten die musste unter relativ sein drucker neun kandidatin dann finden sie haben diese diese sehr ernsthafte coole gute frau ist sally gefunden und dann
plötzlich dann in den naschen community der partei neu die will will wollen wir ja nicht die haben die fahnen und enorm viel drücke setzen sie musste dann zurückdrehen,
das ist was tut ihr da also,
das bedeutet also alltägliches politisches professionelles muss eine eine gute so vorgehensweise bei der beide.
Da bei der kandidatinnen vorstellungen das ging auch über bord.
Ich finde es kaum so kaum zu glauben wie wie wie unprofessionell dieses wahlkampf ist von von von.
Besonders von den konservativen und leiber zum teil von den liberalen,
und die idealen ausnahme ist wie so viel in den so so oft in den letzten paar jahren die einzige ausnahme ist die npd.
Die mit inhalten arbeiten.
Die haben sie haben dann hat ist vollkommen und professionell die kommunizieren ja recht
gut um mach eine professionelle anweise die haben die vermeiden hauptsächlich kann da kann da l oder die dieses große skandal für die also diese sexuelle belastung problemen für der ehemalige parteivorsitzende alexander also
das also der nicht an zumindest ja also
die jetzt die leute die jetzt kandidieren hast du die sind ja kluge und professionelle leute also warum lernen die anderen parteien von diese von diesen menschen.
So ein bisschen so ein bisschen italienischen verhältnissen haben wir glaube ich auch schon mal darüber gesprochen dass.
Aber als ich ja aber als ich sie parteipolitisch aktiv war in großbritannien vor einem jahrzehnt es
kaum zu glauben dass die parteien stecken in so vielen verrückt
nun um komplizierten situationen also schau mal zurück auf alten tweets oder unten
blog beiträge oder wenn man etwas entdeckt hatte zumindest man braucht eine klare erklärung warum hat man da zu dem zeitpunkt geschrieben das haben die ja auch nicht
da ist es kaum zu glauben.
Du verzweifelt ein bisschen an deinem heimatland.
Ja ja ja genau genau versteh mich nicht falsch das ist hier kein paradies aber der situation in großbritannien.
Das ist offensichtlich deswegen sprechen wir da ja auch darüber.
Wenn wir jetzt mal die wahrscheinlich jetzt annehmen und es kommt tatsächlich zu diesem der annahme des bremens und damit offiziell zum austritt großbritanniens.
Dann.
Ist ja damit sozusagen ein deal ein das zukünftige verhältnis großbritanniens zur eu ungeklärt wenn man jetzt sagt okay das bleibt jetzt so wie es jetzt ist.
Was bedeutet denn das eigentlich also,
denn dann das verhältnis großbritanniens zum rest der welt und zur junge.
So also zuerst wird es keine konkrete bedeutung haben bis ende zwanzig zwanzig
also was bedeutet das personen freizügigkeit wir bleiben also alles so alle.
Beziehungen so werden weiterhin sein bis die die.
Bis jetzt die zwei jahren danach könnte es auch der fall sein also wenn diese wenn diese übergangs periode dann noch länger.
Dauern muss.
Ich vermute ja schon dass es länger down wird also das bedeutet bis ende zwanzig zwanzig zweiundzwanzig würdest dann.
Gar keine große änderungen so alltägliche praktische änderungen geben
in großbritannien so beziehung mit anderen länder die eu wird ja schon eine große
auswirkungen haben was bedeutet das die große teile mit ernsthaft ernsthaft versuchen vornehmen um bessere verbindung mit anderen regionen der welt.
Aufzubauen die frage ist inwiefern diese versuche.
Gut funktionieren können die konservativen wetten viel auf eine gute handelsbeziehungen mit dem vereinigten staaten zum beispiel aber das ist natürlich mit trump verbunden also wie sie sowas aus wenn schon dann nächstes jahr nicht gewinnt.
Ich vermute eher dass großbritannien wird dann.
Noch ängstliche sein und not noch nach innen blicken da also einfach mal nervöser als land es wird
großbritannien wirtschaftlich nicht,
gehen weil dann alle firmen die noch so gewartet haben müssen dann ernsthaft an man entscheidungen treffen okay wir wissen ja dass großbritannien,
dann richtig raus sein ende zwanzig zwanzig oder ende zwanzig zweiundzwanzig also was bedeutet das großbritannien es könnte großbritannien schrittweise wirtschaftlich
schlechte gehen wenn dann großen auto firmen zum beispiel werden da entscheidungen treffen die fabriken zu schließen es wird auch natürlich mal wieder zu der frage kommen wird dann schottland dann um unabhängig sein.
Es könnte dann sehr problematisch sein wenn boris johnson und die konservativen lehnen das dann aber es könnte sehr strittig werden.
Ab in beziehung mit anderen länder der eu also die beziehung sind schon echt problematisch also ich vermute die werden dann weiterhin.
Problematisch bleiben also was ist grob.
Meine gruppen eine vermutung parteien in großbritannien die konservativen werden ein riesiges erfolg dann feiern,
aber die werden dann in ein paar jahren dann sehen ja vielleicht war es doch nicht so gut verwenden es großbritannien dann schlecht geht wenn noch ein unterhaus war verloren hat
ja die chancen dass er das dann überleben kann sind dann vielleicht fünfzig,
also egal wer ihn dann ersetzt es wird so frische luft bringen in der partei egal wer das ist auch jemand von dem so sehr linke seite der,
der label partei wird eine neue aufstellung der brötchen parteien geben auf der so sage ich die seite,
wenn die die die liberalen an bedeutung dann gewinnen also die sind dann die die großen fragen für die monaten ein paar jahren.
Nach dem einunddreißigsten januar so aber muss ich auch sagen dass meine sicht keine besonders optimistische aussicht.
Ja zumal in dieser ganzen debatte immer noch so,
so viel vollkommen ungeklärt ist was es mit den übersee gebieten was es mit geballter was es.
Ja gebrautes gebaute kann nicht kann nicht verteidigt werden also oder sorry kann nicht.
Also hat fast keine rolle also hat keine abgeordneten
vielleicht wird kurz mitteilen ja einfach mal sagen okay wir müssen eine sonde lösung für gebrautes dann verhandeln aber spielt zur zeit keine rolle ändern in die jetzt gebaut in großbritannien alle haben das einfach mal vergessen
die übersee gebiete.
Es ist nicht so wichtig weil die idee haben eine andere beziehung mit großbritannien hast die französische übersee gebiete so wie sie die sind ja nicht offiziell teil der eu also was bedeutet da erwarte ich
keine große spannung.
Na ja also
inseln die profitieren schon von den eu richtlinien also unter anderem erlaubt halt die zugehörigkeit großbritannien zur eu den fall klein inseln halt in argentinien auf basis der einigung die eu mit argentinien hat
dort ihre fisch.
Verfahren ja.
Verkaufen und das würde dann auch nicht mehr möglich sein womit sozusagen die wirtschaft der verkleidet inseln von heute auf morgen zu.
Ihr vielleicht aber das ding ist da wir wissen
da wissen wir ja nicht also inwiefern ist boris boris johnson bereit für die interessen von den vogtländer eines oder von gibraltar zu kämpfen
wenn es geht um diese zukünftige beziehung oder finden diese leute eine eigene lösung ist
erneuten deutlich größer im büro in brüssel geöffnet also einfach mal so seine eigene lobbyarbeit gegenüber die institutionen zu machen also ich vermute dann das für die übersee gebiete es wird dann ähnlich sein.
Aber aber das spielt in großbritannien zu sein kaum eine rolle.
Also um wieder sozusagen die alte größe des empire zu bekommen durch diesen brexit schmeißt man an die adresse des auch nochmal komplett überhaupt.
Dann zuerst ja gebrauchte nur zwanzig tausend menschen ja vor jahren sehr weit weg also nordiren ja die haben eine eigene politische system ist ja echt relativ ja schottland ja wir mögen ihn auch so.
Wir haben ja eine lösung an der grenze da und man landet dann und dann wird dann beginne dann eine unabhängigkeitsbewegung in mails auch scheiße wir haben dann nur england.
Irgendwie also.
Geht ja auch die ganze zeit nur in england hat man den eindruck es ist einfach.
Ja genau ja ja stimmt hier zu.
Der brexit ist eigentlich einen engen excel.
Ja
Und dann wie sieht es dann aus mit den englischen regionen also besonders die pro eu dann eine sonderstatus für london
ballon hat mehrheitlich für den für den verbleib gestehen will den finanzindustrie irgendwie verteidigen ja also ist.
Die die konservativen haben sich nicht ernsthaft mit diese ganze problematik
beschäftigt weil es ging einfach um wir mussten brexit liefern die haben ja,
keine ahnung jetzt mehr warum es ist so eine so ein,
das argument ist so ein in einem kreis wir steigen jetzt aus und wir müssen weiter aussteigen weil die leute in zwanzig siebzehn gestimmt haben dass wir aussteigen müssen also
keine rolle mehr wir müssen das machen wir heute weil wir das machen müssen also.
Es ist eine irrsinn geworden also und ja in großbritannien muss ich dann sehr schnell ernsthaft mit diese themenfeldern beschäftigen nachdem einunddreißigsten januar wenn die konservativen am zwölften dezember in mehrheit gewonnen haben und das ist,
dann genau warum aus meiner sicht es echt blöd wäre wenn die konservativen verfügen dann über eine mehrheit weil
es gibt keine mehrheitlichen unterstützung von dieser arten von ideen auch kein mehrheitlichen unterstützen mehr für brexit insgesamt in großbritannien zu zeit also dann wenn die konservativen wir kriegen dann um eine mehrheit der oder sitzt im brötchen unterhausen mit
fünfunddreißig prozent der abgegebenen stimmen,
wäre eine schande aus meiner sicht dann das alles auszuführen
aber das ist wie die britische demokratische system funktioniert weiter.
Dann waren wir doch nochmal einen optimistische ausblick weil wir lassen uns von dreiundsechzig prozent wahrscheinlichkeit ja nicht gleich hinters licht für.
Ist ja auch nur wahrscheinlichkeiten das kann auch immer noch anders kommen wenn es halt diese minderheiten also diese andere situation gebe mit der minderheitsregierung die schon angesprochen hast oder eben auch eine koalition konstellation.
Was wäre da überhaupt vorstellbar also leber und zusammen.
Eine minderheitsregierung der partei ist wahrscheinlicher mit unterstützung von liberalen nationalisten und so weiter es wird nur aus meiner sicht eine relativ schwach und kurzfristige,
regierung sein aber dieser region könnt großbritannien hin in so einem,
zweites referendum dann bringen bis sommer next nächstes jahr und es wäre dann auch dann danach vielleicht ende des jahres nächstes jahr dann erneut und herausfallen dann erforderlich.
Schon mit einem neuen wahlsystem.
Ja das wäre ja hoffen also weil die liberalen und schottischen nationalisten sind zumindest für eine reform der wahlsystem also sowas wenn die eine einigung finden können
wäre sowas dann vielleicht möglich.
Meine hoffnung wäre ein.
Ausreichend sitze für diese oppositionsparteien.
Mit die schotten und die liberalen besonders stark.
Mit laber besonders schwach weil dann
ist ja sicher das label wird unter diese drei parteien die die die stärkste kraft sein ja egal wie die ab die abschnitten in den meinungsumfrage aber dann zumindest dann macht man hatte dann eine hoffnung ok jetzt nehmen wir diese
performance des teams verfassungskonform dann ernst also das wäre,
den weg wäre dann ein zweites referendum verfassungskonform.
Erneute wahlen bis ende zwanzig zwanzig uhr anfang zwanzig einundzwanzig mit einer so neu aufgestellt parteiensystem wo man hat dann,
so eine
konservative brexit partei man hat also eine mitte rechts liberale fdp mäßige partei man hatte gehört grün und so linken laber also.
Die deutsche verhältnisse.
Ja und und dann dann und dann schaut sich nationalisten und und nationalisten dann dann dann auch hinzu also das wäre.
Haben wir ja auch csu.
Ja genau sowas das wäre das wäre meine lieblingsübung es ist nicht unmöglich aber leider wegen diese brüche wahlsystem.
Die chancen sind leider noch eher gering dass man so ein punkt erreichen kann aber es besteht ich besteht noch eine chance.
Na gut dann denke ich mal haben wir die aktuelle situation ganz gut wieder zusammen gefegt bekommen,
vielen dank john ich hoffe,
das wäre noch grund haben genauso freudig wieder zusammenzukommen wie auch immer das jetzt ausgeht aber jetzt wäre das alles verfolgen möchte also erstmal wäre hier.
Noch britische staatsbürgerschaften hat sollte sich vielleicht schleunigst um eine registrierung kümmern.
Ja also man kann sich noch eintragen bis zum fünfundzwanzigsten november
und alle bringen die seit weniger als fünfzehn jahren im ausland sind haben noch das stimmrecht also hab ich empfehl ein
wenn man schickt an anderen personen so den wahllokal weil wegen den probleme mit dem britischen post,
man man hat keine sicherheit dass die post die unterlagen deutschland erreichen
ausreichend zeit vor der unterhaus war damit ich dann pünktlich dann zurückgeschickt werden können also was ist das ist meine mama das wäre mein.
Heißt man muss jemand anderen dort kennen der für einen abstimmt und möglichst jemand auf dem man sich verlassen kann.
Ja genau aber das ist möglich und man kann sich eintragen bis zum fünfundzwanzigsten november.
Okay tja noch irgendwelche wünsche.
Nee einfach nur das alle machen das ist die einzige hoffnung.
Genau techniker punkt watt und die anderen links findet ihr alles in den shownotes vielen dank john vielen dank fürs zuhören das war's mit pkw die brexit serie schreitet voran.